chair the meeting is now Lively
councillor Elgar beneath your microphone
I think cats come in everybody and just
before we start I've just gotta know
I've just got a note for committee
members and it's following on from our
discussion regarding war members
participation in council meetings it's
just so that you all know this has been
deferred and we'll be going to standard
shortly thank you so I could afternoon
everybody
and we're going to stop this proceedings
today slightly differently so I'm going
to ask the council committee members but
actually do a roll call and this will be
facilitated by our principal Clark
Thank You chair so in the meeting room
today we have counselors William
Armitage Jayne Barry
Andrew Cooper Mark Foster David Hancock
Carol Huckabee mode Potts Alan Powell
Tracey reader
Jackie Ridgeway Kathy rouse and yourself
chair Diana Rock
thank you
you're all probably aware this is f
and maybe the last time we hope the
planning committee but using soft way
and we do now have a protocol in place
in the way that this is going to work
facilitate so I'm going to ask their
principal Clark who will read out the
protocol where the following meeting
excuse me churches before that would be
helpful to a committee if um had a roll
call also of the officers you'll be
assisting you today
just to assist with that chair in this
one you in terms of a if we start with
apologies I think there's a little bit
of a delay there so just just to help
just to help with identify who the
officers are in the meeting room we have
Richard Purcell who's the head of
planning we have Adrian Kirkham who is
the planning manager we have Colin
Wilson who is the case officer for this
we have Jim fields and from legal
there's myself Nicola caliber and the
governance manager I'll be facilitating
the meeting we have Alan Moore who's the
senior governments officer who'll be
clocking we have Dana Stanton and a
nearby and also from the governance team
in the meeting room today
thank you thank you thank you
so
Allen do you want to take a reading out
the way forward I think that'll be the
year facilitator will do that chair
Thank You Allen so just in regard to
further in terms of the etiquette that
we use for the today's meeting if you
could please mute your microphones we
may have an issue with feedback so if we
keep all our microphones muted until
we're ready to speak it does help with
that it also can indicate to the chair
and the vice chair and the chamber if
you wish to speak by turning on your
microphone for public speakers in the
meeting today we're asking you if you
can keep your microphones off and your
cameras off until calls on by the chair
during the debate the chair will invite
members to make themselves known at the
commencement of the debate but if after
that point if members do decide they
would like to speak on the application
that we that we are discussing today
please either unmute your microphone to
indicate their wish to speak or you can
use the chat bar to write speak in if
the chair or vice chair don't see you I
will try my best to fly back up to the
chair in terms of voting today we'll use
a mixture of methods on the regular
agenda items it will be a raise of hand
that the chair and vice chair will be
able to see from the chamber for the
applications it will be done by recorded
vote although it won't be recorded as
such in the minutes if you do have any
tech problems during the meeting
everybody should have my phone number or
Martin's phone number please give me a
call or it uses the chat function and
white tech support Thank You chair
thank you that will stop first item on
the agenda is apologies for absence and
non have been received yeah
thank you and we'll move on then to no
produce declaration of interest again
neither being received here
thank you this is to approve the minutes
of the last meeting is a correct record
as
all the members had a chance to look at
them read them and our is their remover
Council on culture thank you is there a
second house where Armitage chair thank
you thank you girls man thank you
all those in favor let me show hands
whatever can't see you can't see chair
all the members have raised their thank
you very much
thank you yeah thank you
item four to report for the planning
applications slightly different for this
and the main part about business so I
can pause the consideration of the
planning applications and as you can
each the individual applicants as its
own reporting us
certain items 4a and 4b I'm happy with
this only tend to use it as a running
order however before we consider the
first of these I would like the clock to
explain how the individual applications
will be dealt with yes thank you check
and members hear me yes yeah okay thank
you right Thank You chair this is the
procedure for considering applications
at the meeting we were considered the
two applications in the order that they
are sent out on the agenda although as
you've said there will be a break
between them the chair will introduce
the application she will then apps ask
the planning officers to explain to
members any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued the
late acts women's agenda supplements
have been published on the council's
website and the link has been sent to
committee to committee members
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation this will set out the
application plans and photographs from
the size the
showing this presentation will be shared
with those attending the meeting
they can also be seen on the council's
website through its YouTube channel
channel following on from this the chair
will ask each of the speakers and award
members first followed by objectors then
the applicant with our agent to speak to
the committee each speaker will have
three minutes to put forward their views
using the conferencing facility
there will be a reminder given by the
clock when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speakers three minutes
members of the committee will have an
opportunity to us the speaker questions
the purpose of these questions to
clarify any points that have been made
when we have heard from all speakers on
an application the chair will open up
the meeting for debate by the committee
and determination by a vote a note for
speakers once the application you have
come to speak on has been dealt with you
may leave the virtual meeting
if you choose to remain then please mute
your microphone and turn off your camera
you will not be allowed to participate
further on in the meeting from that
point
Roger aware this meeting is being
live-streamed
the council will make a recording of the
meeting for purposes of preparing the
minutes once the minutes have been
approved by the committee then this
recording will be deleted but please
note that others may record the
livestream of the meeting from the
internet Thank You chair
thank you thank you that we'll move on
to the first application in this is in
forward slash nineteen course slash zero
zero seven eight six /l FL the car peach
Hong Kong at Holmes field but could this
is you remember their normal practice
I'm going to ask our planning officer to
tell us that so anyway comment reports
that we've been that's been produced and
for the planning manager it it was a
brief present changed is showing the
photos and plans at the site the meeting
facilitate emotionally presentation is
on this screen this means I might find
it difficult to see everybody therefore
I will allow the officer to complete his
presentation and ask members to reserve
any points of order or questions about
the process until the end there will be
plenty of time for you to ask Jin's
initiative
you
Thank You chair just in terms Thank You
chair just in terms of the updates and
presentations and calling the case
officer is present in the meeting chair
but as this is the first virtual meeting
I'll take the lead but there may be some
point of clarification I'll meet to
speak to Colleen about which case I will
identify that and ask you permission to
do so and also chair and nicky's kindly
going to share the presentation with you
but first of all I've got some late
updates and interrupting to the
application to get to members so I'll do
that first firstly chair in addition to
the late representations that members
received yesterday we've had a further
six representations late yesterday and
overnight on the application from
various residents of car be slain at
Holmes field car Lane at Barlow and Main
Road at Holmes field making the
following points
stating that the derailment is
overdevelopment in their opinion and I
saw out of character and not in keeping
with the natural beauty of the area but
that will adversely impact on the
landscape spoil views demolish local one
life and be generally unsympathetic to
the conservation area those points chair
and as officers we believe have been
addressed in the report already so I
don't attend to comment further on those
in addition chair got comments received
from councillor Angelique Foster and she
asks first of all that the application
is postponed as she has been informed
that residents had not had enough notice
to comment and no notice been placed in
the local parish paper which is the
usual way changes firstly on that point
as officers we believe that the
application I'm being received at the
end of summer last year and advertised
in the normal way has a plenty of
opportunity provided plenty of
opportunity for those who wish to
comment to make comment on the
application sure and actually have seen
many have done so so officers don't see
any reason for further deferral of the
application today
in addition chair can to foster also
expected concern her concern about the
application as County counselor
considers that the government is
inappropriate in its scale within the
Greenbelt and also that the development
would have a
mental impact and openness with access
to the development presenting an issue
due to poor visibility on the cartilage
lane with the cumulative impact the
increase in traffic being negative
overall and we'll have see some features
of that shortly chair just in
introduction members will recall the
application with was deferred a
committee in March and it's represented
now to committee for consideration and
determination although it is unaltered
as the applicant did not wish to amend
the scheme further to members
consideration in March the application
share proposes the demolition of a
number of structures the conversion of
one to our dwelling the construction of
four new build dwellings and their
attention and then conversion of all the
traditional buildings to be used
ancillary to the new residential units
the site Gerry is primarily located in
the Greenbelt where it's at accepted the
new build Wellings are generally
inappropriate whereas the conversion of
existing buildings is generally
considered acceptable however share one
caveat that is that the development of
brownfield sites as here may be
acceptable if the new development would
not have a greater impact on the
openness the Greenbelt than the existing
development officers have concluded
churner set out in the report that while
spatially the proposed development would
not have a greater impact on the
Greenbelt visually it would resulting in
an officer view that the proposal is in
that context inappropriate development
however chair if the reasons set out in
the report officers consider the overall
benefits of the scheme the removal of
the inappropriate buildings and the
retention and refurbishment of others
represents the very special
circumstances in this case to justify
approving the scheme through my members
chaired that they will need to pay
special regard to the site's location
within the Conservation Area the reasons
set out in the officer report charities
concluded the impact of the dwelt is
offset by the wider benefits I have
already mentioned officers chair have
already and weighed the technical
matters and concludes the new view of
the site's extant use the limited level
of development proposed there would be
no one except will impact and highway
safety
inclusion share there are no technical
reasons to resist the application so it
is recommended accordingly the
permission is granted Mickey is able to
help Cheryl just run through the slides
that and most members I'm sure would
recall from from March but we'll just
run through them again
you
thanks Nick if you just go down to the
third slide please thank you and we'll
have seen yesterday chair and we'll
learn through the virtual site visit
that we we undertook the site occupy the
site at the southern end of Holmes field
and as I say most of the site lies
within the Greenbelt
and you'll just be able to see on the
side as you you can see it there the
very civil the end there's the bungalow
and then a Dutch barn and also to the
bottom end of the site there's a variety
of buildings that we'll see on the
photographs in a second that are in
association with the the extant livery
use on the site but are currently and
generally unkempt than the buildings for
the north into the beside property or
town field of those that are are
generally a greater character and
support Conservation Area aims an object
is generally just move on and Mickey
please so this is the site outlined in
red journalist as I say it's just the
south of home field and you just be able
to make out cottage Lane going north
from the sides during the main highway
network if you just move on again
Mickey please
thanks one beat thank you
this shows the side is probably
developed and you'll be able to to see
at the bottom left of the red line site
and there are four dwellings that's
where the four dwellings would be placed
red circle often they relate to three
and visa take the developed and they'll
be a good indicator when we come to look
at the photographs in a sec
I will be the retention known as the
freshing behind the buildings that are
to the south there would be removed and
that would form your the dwelling and
then the other four buildings on the
site would be renovated and returned to
a use and they would support the
residential uses on the side just move
on Mickey please just go to the next one
as well thank you
this shows the buildings in red that
would be removed and leave the side
those that are left outlined being the
remainder so the bottom left corner is
the existing bungalow that you'll see on
the photographs and a second is a little
dancing rebuilding behind that the large
red building is the Dutch barn that will
be removed the large grouping of
buildings to the bottom right those that
are associated with the threshing barn
currently they too would be removed as
would three smaller buildings to the
north of the threshing barn the others
being retained thanks Nicky
this is the northern and eastern
elevation of the threshing bark showing
how the existing openings are going to
be reused and windows and doors placed
in them to support the residential use
next one Nikki please thank you and then
this is the southern elevation which is
the top of that shot than the western
elevation which is the lower drawing
again showing how the existing openings
will be used in that barn to permit its
conversion to a dwelling house thanks
Nikki you come on now to the or new
build dwellings just in the right hand
corner you can see the the red square or
oblong rectangle that denotes where
these buildings would be this building
would be located this is the pair of
semi-detached units and again Nikki
we've come unto thee as the roof plan of
the semi-attached units and taking and
we come on to the elevations of the
detached units our proposed
we return again Nikki please and let's
find that some the red blob in the top
right that's the one of the detached
humans they don't with your the detach
unit is next on the list but it's
similar in design to that one might have
hoop ton again and at the Lord please
the the other detached unit is similar
in design to the one and you see more
this said there are two and one tile you
see the one on the left is a photograph
of what the site looks in its existing
for the one on the right showing what it
would look like and you can just make
out in the middle of the photo on the
right the semi-attached units that are
proposed let's move on to the next one
there Nikki please this shows the site
from the southern edge of the site you
can see on the left-hand side you just
make out the very edge of the bungalow
with the ancillary building next door
those are the three trees that I'd
mentioned earlier on which would be
removed and behind there is the Dodge
Barn and they would be replaced with one
of the detached units that you can see
and the photograph on the right and to
the right of there is one of the
retained ancillary buildings the
building on the furthest right the
converted threshing barn as it would
look and as you can see the sudden
elevation utilizing the existing
openings I think if we move on to some
photographs now
thank you this is a photograph and in
effect taking from the other 180 degrees
from the montage we've just seen so this
looks south to the right is the line
that's the footpath that then descends
into the bellethorpe Valley you can just
make out the existing riding arena on
the left and this is just the view
towards the the mill thought value as
you can see the site just fall away to
that valley and beyond the edge of the
site and to the valley bottom than the
the hills further beyond thanks Nikki
this is taken from the same location as
the one we've seen between be exactly
the other direction you can see here on
the left the bungalow that would be
demolished and you have the shared which
would also be demolished the trees that
I've made reference to behind which is
the Dutch barn which would also be
demolished then the three buildings on
the right the buildings of some
character that would be retained and
refurbished to the one to the furthest
right being the threshing barn you can
just make out in front of their
buildings that have been erected to
support the previous uses which would be
also demolished facilitating its
conversion and we're closer at one of
those next I think Nicky thank you yes
that shows the buildings that would be
removed which currently on-site
supporting the previous and stamping use
which would be demolished and taken away
as part of any approval granted thank
you
should go into the heart of the sign now
this is a close-up picture that the
deutsche bahn is the building on the
left and then the other two buildings
will be retained and refurbished Thank
You Vicki
and sweeping round to the
the threshing barn there two buildings
on the left to the buildings will be
retained thank you
this is taken now from the location and
looking back towards Holmes field of the
proposed center it's actually units
there's an existing dwelling there that
is on the access drive to the right to
meeting as you enter the site this would
be an area of God to serve those
semi-detached units now we swing around
Mickey just gradually coming around to
the east and then further to the east
next one please
looking back then towards those
buildings there would be retained with
the one in the furthest right the
threshing barn and if you come round
again those two a closer one of the
Dutch barn and if you just move on again
please
again she's looking back along what
would become the the access road into
the site so the access into the dwelling
houses would just be beyond the building
on the left and what go in there to
access the four houses on the left-hand
side building directly on the right
would be retained but then the wall that
you can just see beyond it with the
window in would be removed thank you
it's looking back towards the threshing
barn again you can see the openings in
the existing building which will be
utilized to the silicate age conversion
and whether the cursor is just to the
moment that is part of the building that
would be removed thanks Nicky
and this is looking back towards those
buildings we just discuss building on
the left be retained building on the
right he would be retaining just see the
threshing barn beyond this this is the
access the would facilitate access to
those five new units and we should turn
around they can go back towards the this
is looking back towards the site yet the
building on the left immediate left will
be retained and just make out the Dutch
barn in the middle top of the shot and
then the two cemeteries would be this
side off there I'm sneaky this is the
access into the site on the right-hand
side that's a shot and that we saw on
the site visit yesterday that's some
coffees lane as it goes into the bridle
track that leads down towards Barlow
thanks Nikki this is the existing made
Road that joins the side to car fish
lane on the right hand side is the
listed structures that have mentioned
thank you sure to then take some shots
up here at the access this is looking
towards homes field in the so-called
critical direction then the final one
Nikki should be in the other direction
showing the non-critical directions
that's looking left out of the access
road that he joins to the sides then
onto the highway network which is
carbage language you can just see on the
right there I think that's all Nikki
thank you Thank You Jay thank you are
there any questions for April at this
point in time on members okay we'll move
on then to the first speaker for this
application and I believe it's the ward
member councillor Carol Huckabee
Carol if you can unmute
and so a hooker be can you hear us yes
we can now yes okay
Cottage Lane hold on can you hear me
yeah Kim Kimmy
okay
Cantus hall farm is on the edge of the
Cavaliers Conservation Area and as such
should preserve and enhance the area
using materials in keeping with the
adjacent stone buildings not using metal
cladding which is on two of the houses
sister going up which is inappropriate
with the history of the old agricultural
area there's insufficient parking on
site and would not allow adequate
overflow parking the visitors or
delivery buns the solution to the
problem of footpath 26 at the moment
he's got to be addressed because at the
moment it follows the truck straight
through the farm he causing potential
hazards to both workers and delivery
vans and horses the these proposals
would result in a detrimental impact on
the Clipper Conservation Area in visual
in visual terms adjacent properties
served by large vehicles and
agricultural tractors the lane is not
wide enough to allow any adequate vans
or anything to pass one another the
parish council raised concerns about the
number of objections to the proposal on
the basis that there is need for
development but it needs keeping in it
but it needs to be keeping with the area
access to the site from the lane is it's
a difficult junction which continues to
have problems with speeding motorists
negotiating the benzylic mill for blame
which is incidentally been knocked down
twice in the last two months
Carter's Lane comes to an end just at
the entrance of the site and also to the
end
and it's to bring Woodgate bridle-path
this old farm is not suitable for modern
housing which would change the character
and and of the surrounding buildings and
country styling on the surrounding
buildings and and everywhere in there is
is very difficult to go through the site
the area from the main entrance is only
a track and when you think of all these
cars extra cars that will be going
through also with well 30 seconds I have
had an ester here from lutely Roli with
your vast advice and in his committee
takes a step back if the committee
yourselves takes a step back it is clear
that this application in its size and
bulk from Basra plain placement impacts
on the green bar belts impact on the
conservation area location and approach
does not align with either the space of
the framework rules or these important
issues which can carry on based on oh
I'm at least okay remember this tariff
occasion no okay we'll move on to the
next video which is a mr. Michael
daughter
you
mr. dorsen oh hello Jared can you hear
me now
you have three minutes mr. dorsen can
you hear me now the first thing and most
importantly not the first thing and most
important thing that I want to state is
that this proposed application is
inappropriate the over development of a
conservation site this is an
inappropriate over development of a
Greenbelt area this site is within the
Sheffield Greenbelt and the National
Planning policy framework states very
clearly quote inappropriate development
is by definition harmful to the
Greenbelt and should not be approved
except in very special circumstances the
buildings that are on there now there
are not special circumstances and are
not needed to be saved to our our mini
house in the state to be built we are
then concerned about the weight being
applied in the conclusions which has led
to a recommended conditional approval
particularly around the repeated
assertions of offices that in this this
application will somehow save existing
buildings this is a flawed framing of
this application and as local residents
we would ask that the committee
disregard this assertion for which no
proof is offered in making their final
determination the size bulk and height
of each of these new designs will have a
negative impact on the beautiful
countryside they do not blend into the
Greenbelt area but actually stand out as
an eyesore and the blight on the
landscape they will be a visual
intrusion of this conservation and
Greenbelt area officers are conceded in
the summary that the openness of the
Greenbelt is not preserved by this
application and sizable buildings which
are relatively conspicuous are being
proposed the officers also accept there
will be harm to the local area from a
visual perspective that is contrary to
the NPP f and to local any DDC policies
also the access road is not suitable for
more traffic especially
the farm traffic it is narrow and the
junction where cartridge lane and mill
fault line meets is a North fall
junction where car drivers can't see
both ways unless they pull well into the
road increased traffic will increase the
likelihood of accidents if the committee
takes to step back it is clear that this
application interesting in his size
fault proposed replacement impacts on
the Greenbelt impact on the conservation
area location and approach does not
align with private the spirit of the
framework rules on these important
issues based on that alone in district
addition disregarding any absence of
some state there anyway it should be
rejected at the application the building
should be rejected are there any
questions for mr. Dawson hello yes yeah
right we've got three minutes okay right
ladies and gentlemen of the Planning
Committee
I was speaking not only for myself but
my wife but also from those listed below
who has to be supported to give their
support a key issues surrounding this
planning application is that it was
sensibly deferred at the committee
meeting on the 10th of March the further
review and amendment but there has been
no information whatsoever published
regarding any amended proposal and you
to lock down the matter has been
sidelined the first related
communication in the public in the head
was dated and posted on 18th of June
this
as a notice from Richard Purcell head of
planning advising that the application
was to be on the agenda of this meeting
today but the time the mail was opened
on the 22nd of June this allowed just
eight days preparation then by mail by
email of the 23rd of June we were
informed that application had been
recommended for approval conditional but
no detail this development has very very
serious applications it violates green
bells in his subject
conservation area compliance search a
limited period of time allocated for
interested and affected parties to catch
up and consider what is transpired
behind closed doors since the 10th of
March is blatantly undemocratic and
unacceptable as far as I can discern the
short time available the developer has
not taken the opportunity to resolve the
major issues that had been flagged
since submitting this said this
submission in advance of today's meeting
I received a copy of the supplementary
agenda containing 16 objections the case
officers comments on every single one
are exactly the same
officers consider that the relevant
matters raised have been covered in the
office officer report this looks like a
complete whitewash and they certainly
haven't covered to local satisfaction
the TP re has expressed serious concern
that recent changes in the planning
system introduced as a result of curve
at 19 could be abused in the short term
or allowed to undermine community led
funny hopefully this will not be the
case I have an immense commitment to
cartilage Hamlet my wife family Nate
jolly have lived in the cordon fairly
since the 16th century I've lived a
cartridge [ __ ] grade two-star the 40
years of sympathy restored synthetic
restored cottage bridge grade to
perpetuating active farming cartridge
Grange farm and renovated the dormer
bunglers Road at 66 car 3 my other
resident other residents have restored
the stone on stone detached cottages
adjacent to the cartridge Hall farm
everything has been done remove
protective HAMP's the historic value of
the hamlet maintaining its remarkable
historic buildings and rural culture
thank you are there any questions
no we move on to the next speaker
mr. Grissom Amy mother
can you hear me lady sorry okay
oh yeah first of all I should like to
say that it's repeatedly on these
objections that know who notices seem to
have appeared at Carthage so I don't
know if that's quite legal I don't know
I'm not okay with the planning I'm
really speaking I'm chairman of the
whole skillful button bridleway society
the society was formed about 45 years
ago and has been very active over many
years
Willie A's with the Parish Council also
the rights away Department at mass flow
the planning application in question is
bisected by a very busy footpath in our
parish consequently from the health and
safety point of view it will be a major
hazard especially in the construction
phase which will be prolonged as it is
probably the largest development in the
parish for many years
furthermore on the health and safety
issue the junction of Carthage laying
cuvee site with mill tolling is another
major hazard with at least two actions
there to my knowledge in the last few
years how committed the footpath
Committee believes it will be foolhardy
to approve this application so I plead
on behalf of our society the people of
Homs film and many others who walk this
footpath to turn down the end this
application we have to bear in mind
especially in this of my mum's this
footpath is used by families with young
children heaven forbid if an accident
should happen the planners would have
this on their conscience it is to come
so please please don't approve this
application thank you for listening
I'll surrender
can you turn your microphone back on
sorry about them and I just wanted to
ask the gentleman in the report it just
say that the applicant is going to seek
to divert the foot packs does he
consider that this would address the
issue that he's happy
well the footpath at the moment is an
anomaly because the old maps seem to
show that the footpath goes through the
the barn the threshing barn and it's not
being determined where the footpath is
so until that sorted out I think they
should put the planning application on
hold anyway and I don't know we don't
know where the footpath would finish you
whether it's going to stay as it is or
going to be diverted lower down onto the
bring wood gate brag away that this
should have been sorted before the
meeting really
and you go the questions thank you we'll
move on to the next speaker and more in
Greenland
you
hello dr. Greenland would you like to
you and meet your microphone
would you like to try that again dr.
Greenland
you
doctrine and you're still muted
chair would you like to move on to the
next speaker and come back to dr.
Greenland at the end
yes that's fine a new blonde about
Norwood hello
sorry hello I'm a resident cartilage
laying I've viewed the plot these new
properties in the renovation of the
existing farm and outbuildings and I'm
very concerned about the number of new
residences replacing one bungalow
resulting in an overall kapin sea of the
area the proposal to build large
proctors with a large proportion of
metal cladding does not fit in nor does
it merge into the surrounding vernacular
presently there is a metal barn on the
land the MIS barn has deteriorated over
the years and become quite an eyesore
all the thoughts of the architect and
proposer to base the material choices on
the ruin of the barn let us remember
that the proposed planning is for
domestic residences and not farm
buildings a majority of the surrounding
houses cottages and several buildings of
local interest at Carthage Hall are made
of beautiful stone the farm buildings
within these plans are also built of
stone some dating back to the 15th
century and all all of which are of
historical interest to many walkers
using the footpath malcom the proposed
would justify the erection of four
houses with metal cladding in addition
to all this is a safety of road users
and walkers through eleven parking
spaces designated for these properties
with 19 bedrooms where would visitors
park with this result in them parking
down Cottage Lane where the road is
narrow and is a regular access for a
farmer with his tractor as you approach
and leave the proposed development area
the junction with the bridle path which
is used regularly by horses and people
walking dogs many are
there will be an increase in traffic
down Cartledge lane towards the
dangerous drink junction with middle
thought laid many of the residents have
to approach the junction on the opposite
side of the lane to view the oncoming
traffic may I bring it to your attention
that there have been several accidents
at this Junction residences 62 and 66 of
their roadside walls
demolished several times costing
thousands of pounds to love the recent
accident services resulted in vehicles
being wedged in the stone walls
completely destroying them daily my
husband and I - serious contemplate
getting in and out of our driveway which
is just beyond the blind corner
disjunction and finally it is it not
easy to win but a conservation area
should be enhanced by any new
development I fear this certainly would
not had anything but only take away from
the idyllic location of a local beauty
spot and also we've got to consider the
nature in that area the owl barns and
the bats thank you thank you are there
any questions no thank you thank you has
Maureen greatly been able to come back
that's Greenland which you like to try
and unmute your microphone again hailing
that Chad you want me to read optigrill
and serve text I know they can't hear me
I'm asking if you can read it
so say he couldn't read it can you tell
me he can read it don't scream and we
can hear you you're like oh oh right
okay right ready just start you go three
should I start to these three minutes
right yes okay I'm also speaking on
behalf
I'm also speaking on behalf of other
neighbors who support my opinions whose
names and addresses I've submitted as
five of them everybody loves the
cartridge area local people visitors
walkers appreciate the history in the
ancient buildings and the tranquil
setting of the old farm with beautiful
countryside
stretching below it the proposed plan to
a mini suburb of big ugly modern houses
is outrageous not only would it spoil
the character of the farm and its
surroundings but it will also contravene
the principles of the conservation area
there are many serious issues that
hadn't been addressed the popular foot
path leading through the farm would
become a hard surface road with
potential hood day hinges for
pedestrians and drivers it would have
spree lighting neighbors have voted
against this additional lights from the
new housing would be seen from near and
far
there were [ __ ] gravel paths and all
the trappings of suburbia the plan for
the new house is close together with
insufficient boots parking space and no
extra provision for visitors and
delivery lorries and so on is ridiculous
the approach to the farm is by way of a
dangerous Junction and narrow roadways
there is no sprue
Road and so vehicles have to go in and
out of the farm on the same narrow route
ethic on Carthage Lane would be doubled
creating more road noise pollution and
difficulties was maneuvering especially
if extra cars were upon the road natural
green space would be reduced affecting
the animals and birds including barn
owls that frequent their rural
environment three years ago an
application for a carport on this same
site was proposed and this committee
rejected the scheme on environmental
grounds and the planned use of
unsympathetic building materials how can
you possibly let this proposal go
through the whole project needs to be
rethought if some kind of development is
really necessary a better use of the
existing buildings should be considered
which might not have such a devastating
impact we're asking you to reject this
planning application because it's
totally inappropriate for this peaceful
settled and much-loved
area and I entirely agree was a thank
you I entirely agree with Ashley Turner
in saying that there has been no time to
properly prepare this meeting and
contact all the people who have since
then contacted and made their comments
thank you thank you no thank you
we'll move on to the keynote speaker
which is the Matthew J Hicks
hello yeah yeah I'm sorry we have mrs.
Foster
shall I go for a minute I'm Julia
you
you could just hang fire thank you I
will do yes you can hear me Julia Foster
you'd like to stop yes if you'd like to
start
yes if you can hear me home as a
resident of cartilage for 49 years as
I've seen many sympathetic changes
enhancing the area living a peaceful
environment for rural activities the
junction of the main road where cottage
laid converges with Milsom Lane
culminating in a narrow and difficult
approach to the hamlet of cottage by the
way the footpath farm entrance and
residence driveways traffic will be
exacerbated and impossible the proposed
housing does not come like the area of
great to list the buildings and other
cottages residence throated snow street
lights years ago to protect wildlife in
a conservation area also within the
Greenbelt on the property was refused
I know planning office and I request
that everyone in the founding office is
acquainted and aware of the danger of
traffic problems which this proposal
will incur well to erect new buildings
in a Greenbelt is not acceptable but to
adopt existing ones may be the answer
but even then for residential use would
be difficult with the one-way approach
to the old farmyard I'm also very aware
of the wildlife that will be destructed
thank you thank you burning questions
for miss Foster thank you you can move
on now to Matthew Jakes
hello can I begin hello Thank You
patience yes please my name is Matty
Jake I am the applicant at Cartledge War
Farm I wanted to make a short statement
today to express what I felt was
important in the consideration of this
application a carefully chose the design
team who worked in collaboration with
North East Derbyshire County Council
planning to achieve what I believe is a
very considered high quality housing
scheme part of which is the renovation
and preservation of the threshing barn
and ancillary buildings development of
the scheme has been ongoing for a long
period of time as to get the support of
all the parties involved and deliver a
well-developed design the viability of
the project has been made harder by the
intense delivers such a high-quality
scheme with the considerable renovation
of viable buildings in the conservation
area there were to be these are to be
used as family homes now for future
generations I could not think of a more
perfect place to grow up as a child or
retire in old age this project will be a
value and benefit to the community both
in bringing people and families into the
area as well as providing work locally
in the building of this scheme there was
an opportunity here to improve the
character of this area by allowing us to
bring back to life the 17th century
threshing barn stripping away all the
20th century additions have been added
over the years as well as building
contemporary housing which will sit at a
juxtaposition to the original group of
earlier buildings while retaining the
Royal feeling through the site layout I
would also like to address and the
concerns to do with traffic by pointing
out that when the livery business was
there there would have been a lot of
traffic going up and down there some of
which would have been horse boxers and
other agricultural traffic I thank you
for your consideration of this
application and hope that you give us
the approval we need to move forward
with this project thank you are there
any questions from members
how to armor delicious entity which is
swollen to
Chancellor Powell yes thank you thank
you sure I just
it's on can you hear me now yeah okay
right yes this is an amended application
oh it was supposed to be could you tell
me what's the difference between this
application which you put in in March
and the application today because as far
as I can see there's been no nothing's
been altered at all perhaps I'm wrong
here could you enlighten me please no
you're correct but going back to you we
had a lot of fears about various things
which were brought up I mean you know
whether it was appropriate or not or the
materials use were brought into question
didn't you think it would have been wise
on your part of amended it slightly I
think I'm the best person to answer that
is Mel our heritage consultant that will
be speaking out for us and the reason
she's here today is to explain that
right Thank You Mel don't your honor
teachers already mentioned the points
that I wanted to make and I will listen
very carefully to what the agent says
thank you can Snow Fairy can notice us
whether at any point you can sort it
with the local neighbors and the people
that are live on Carter plane
no no any further questions but well I
would like to say that there was notice
given for them to make their opinion
known to the planning through the
planning process and we did work with
the planners thank you move on to the
next speaker which is named Morris
apologies chair counsel David Hancock
has indicated his wish to speak
Thank You chase sorry I think we're both
a bit of lag I dropped out briefly as
well it's just to follow up on cows the
berries point and trying to reconcile
what what mr. jenks has just said in
terms of not consulting with the
neighbors to what he said just a few
seconds ago where he's saying that he's
consulted to make this survival project
for everybody unless I'm being really
sick those two things just don't tie up
at all so could you clarify to me how
how you're engaging this to get everyone
I'm sorry I was just pointing out that
and the planning notices are there for
people to put their opinions across and
then you know we do consider those
opinions through the process so we have
taken into account their opinions that
they were put forward through the
planning process with respect so though
you actually gave the implication in
your statement that you proactively sort
consultation that's not proactive and
the stainless with heard from previous
people obviously make it quite clear
they feel that they weren't consulted
sorry I'm I'm not sure what to say and
if you've misconstrued what I said then
I'm sorry
okay hassleberry I think what what's a
counselor I kept trying to get out is
that you can see through the application
form or how many objections have come
forward I think what the trance bring
out is why did you not feel like
important
to actually call a meeting of the
residents to discuss how you're going to
move forward with your plans and whether
they could put some valuable input into
them
closely so we worked very closely with a
lot of consultants one being man who's
going to speak and obviously the
architect planning consultant and the
planners for a very long period of time
this has been ongoing for a few years
and this scheme has been revised and
revised and revised to get to where we
are I feel that we have made a lot of
effort in the design and the thought and
the consideration of this scheme to
deliver what what I feel is and and
hopefully everyone involved feels that
have been through through this process
it is a very good scheme yes thank you
and you say that but I have to say that
you don't appeared either to have
listened to the concerns of the the
members that the council meeting back in
March
there's been no amendment so that that
feels to me like you've taken no notice
of our concerns at that time and not all
members were against this this actual
application there were a lot of merits
in its actual development there were
many concerns about how it was actually
being physically laid out and the
materials that were going to be used and
some of the sides of the properties that
you were actually putting forward so
that that's different definite to
concern for me that you don't appear to
have even taking consideration of the
members I absolutely did very much
consider what was said and and I hope
that that Mel being here today shows
that um and and I just think I need to
leave it to Mel to try and explain
explain us explain the the the
application okay thank
Thank You mr. James now we'll move on to
the next don't see cuts the agent will
Morris good afternoon
um can I just explain lightly thanks Ben
I'm not the agent I am the heritage and
the agent is their planning consultant
oh okay
thank you hello I'm a heritage
conservation consultant and I know
northeast Derbyshire very well having
advised the authority on conservation
matters and and contextual design before
the authority appointed it's there an
in-house conservation hello can you hear
me I think I know the topography the
building materials and the character
experiment I managed the etching
Toontown scheme and then the
conservation area partnership for
several years my involvement with this
site started in November 2018 when I was
appointed to advise on both the historic
buildings on the site and the layout and
location of new developments at the
beginning of the project I was also
involved in the discussion over the
design of the new build element as with
all development where an architect is
involved
I do not interfere unless there is a
good cause however I do at the outset to
provide parameters and I identify
heritage constraints the framework for
the design is now the National design
guide which came out in September 2019
although the guidance came out in 2019
the same principles of good design were
adopted the two main parameters and
constraints for new development which I
identified were as follows one to
respect the important views within and
of the conservation area and how it is
appreciated and these were accepted by
the planning authorities conservation
adviser and two to enable the original
cluster of historic buildings to stand
out as a distinct group not to eat them
or copy their details or create
confusion by adding extensions or
diluting their character and these are
sound conservation principles
accepted by the conservation advisor and
huh
we can't hear you
melodye I think that your audio has
dropped out halfway through your speech
chair I think her audio has disappeared
so she's unable to hear us and of course
she's continuing to read
is it worthwhile moving on to Alex yeah
will do should we move on
I think we move on to the next speaker
that is risky so if I pronounced that
wrong afternoon everybody
I'm now except for third Calatrava so
the brief theory development of cattle
farm is centered around for long
prolonging the life of the existing
fashion barn in historic context through
a comprehensive program of respect
repair restoration and conversion the
proposals aim to preserve the historical
and cultural value of the existing
historic context through the sensitive
repair and reuse of existing buildings
which will help to prevent further
losses to the story building fabric to
facilitate this program of restoration
is intended to provide new high-quality
housing as part of our scheme so during
the design stage is a number of design
options were appraised through
collaboration with male heritage
consultant and the local planning
authority to address the considerations
identified within the Heritage impact
assessment so this is these included the
preservation of key views the retention
of existing footpath network and
attention of the historic group of
buildings including the preservation of
the existing path that runs through the
site each process each proposal soiree
was tested and reviewed with her
heritage consultant and while team to
assess their appropriateness to the same
the architectural responses evolved by
working closely with a heritage
consultant to ensure that the historic
context forms the centerpiece within the
proposed scheme and is the anchor around
which the new dwellings are arranged the
proposal as forms of a mix of four new
three four and five bedroom houses which
arranged carefully around a new
courtyard that continues this northeast
to southwest access defined by the
existing session ban and historic
context and to reflect the collaborative
approach with the heritage consultant
and local planning authority the
informal clustered arrangement of the
new dwellings is broken up through the
scale and massing which allows the key
views to be preserved an existing
footpath to be retained this has been
achieved in part through the design of a
contemporary dormer roof structure that
has been developed with a low each site
to provide
Headroom within the internal spaces so
this minimizes the proposals visual
impact on surrounding buildings and
landscape setting and to preserve the
key views of the historic context from
within and around the site the new
dwellings have also been developed
carefully through regular discussions
with the heritage consultant and local
authority and a fond of pitched fish
stone work playing which grounds the
building in a local material that
emerges from the local sandstone bedrock
duper four levels of design using
contemporary detail and proposed in a
degree metal cladding system to reflect
the look of an active found in the
surrounding questions for the historic
group of buildings remain clear instinct
neutral ins have been carefully designed
to reflect the key feature
characteristics of the concept and the
concept used to sort of shares of stone
welcome after climbing and wild turns of
the timber surround details will
establish a clear design rationale by
anchors the new proposals to the
development site and surrounding
historic context that we believe will
help and the development sit carefully
within the historic setting at the site
Thank You Athena chair are there any
questions
councillor auntie thank you check any
here me yet Thank You chair you
mentioned about the retention of the
footpath which is in can you tell me how
you intend to do this when you consider
that the footpath at the moment is not
on the definite line and you also you
said about the black metal cladding that
that's a feature of the area well any
again tell me how you make out that this
is yeah thank you very much beefy
question and so just just to sort of
approach the first question in terms of
the existing footpath so and you write
as part of the termination process the
the sort of presence of the existing for
exists on some of the
on some of the historic maps you write
just run through the existing fishing
ban but the the existing footpath that
we're looking to attain is the one that
that's currently on site that whopper -
so we're not looking to disrupt that in
any way and that's what we're proposing
to attend the new development
appreciating that there's a little bit
of confusion and clarification needed on
on the existing footpath that runs
through the depression band currently
and in terms the materiality the the
approach to the scheme standard the new
proposals was very much to to ensure
that the new buildings remain clear and
distinct from the historic context so
what we were trying to do with with the
development of the first mesiah was was
tap into some of the surrounding and
question structures in terms of the
materiality - some of that included the
you know more of a contemporary
detailing and that includes the metal
cladding that referred to and we believe
that we can detail that and really
careful and refined where that will
allow the existing group of buildings to
remain Craven yeah if I could just come
back to you on that you say that the
metal cladding as far as I can see the
only really large-scale mented metal
cladding is on the Dutch bond which are
got to demolish though you know I don't
think that really stands the test of
time really would you agree
all right in terms of the Dutch ban and
I would I think the quality of the
construction is far and I completely
agree that the the detail in the of any
proposed metal cladding system would be
would need to be really carefully
considered and refined and considered
carefully with the local authority for
the benefits of approving application is
that elements could be conditioned so we
would fully expect for the external
facade treatment to be conditioned and
for us to be expected to work very
carefully to submit
samples and details - to prove that you
know the water goes into those four
Sciences is well detailed and carefully
considered but you this is an amended
application concerns about the use of
metal cladding and yes it's because
these are the two of them is brilliant
we've got too much you're not really
so I appreciate that and it's totally
fine just to try and answer your
question on on the layout and so thank I
appreciate you actually using this
because I think I think it's a really
important point of discussion so there's
two points but there's two points really
and I've made a lot of notes of last
meeting and also listen to the concert
objections today and I think everything
that has been discussed is fair and I
could understand your you know your
opinions on it firstly just on the
layout and you really write to raise
that and we ourselves as it as a team
really worked hard and at times wrestled
with the layout and what we had to
juggle was in one respect we would we
would try and create more of a core
guard and facility you know a wider four
hero access into that card and make that
more generous but what that would mean
would would be that we have to push
those those buildings and the the dwell
is that we run along the southern edge
of the site further into the green bar
and we didn't want to do that and it
didn't fit as closely with the historic
lines across the stack you know those
historic axis that runs from the from
the from the threshing barn along the
existing building so what what we try to
do you write in you've identified it is
we've we've been we've we've then nudge
those existing or sorry the proposed
dwellings up in line with the existing
building we've been really keen to try
and continue that access across the site
as I said we had tested it and
absolutely we tested options where we'd
we'd push the proposed dwellings further
back into the Greenbelt and you know
we're trying we're really trying our
hardest to try and respect the existing
context so which we decided as a team to
take at the line of the existing fashion
violin and building that society
in terms of the materiality I you know
I've listened to the comments here today
and obviously some a bit for me or is
this is challenging to hear and and I
absolutely take your comments on board
what I can say it's not the detail and
if that cloud is protected and detected
through condition and we and will
continue to work really hard to ensure
that what would it would be the highest
problems I can understand in terms of
elevational drawings that you've seen
you know possibly one to one hundred
ones two hundred wouldn't communicate
the level of detail that you need to see
but what I would say is that that level
of detail can be conditioned and we can
we can interrogate that much further a
larger scale Thank You Barry it's down
has been a 3d you should belong to the
balance what we look to do is to is to
furbish repair and preserve those
existing buildings they would then be
able to be occupied then by the
dwellings so for example they may be
able to be used as a you know for
anything from from storage food to you
know like a new workshop space or studio
so our attention is very much to
preserve than those simple apples and
ciliary just because they're not given a
sort of formal useful and just to
clarify there would be used by the
documents within the dwellings
thank you any further questions thank
you very much Ridgeway
oh hello yes thank you for that I've
been listening very carefully and I take
on board what you said on Ridgeway
yes I'm unmuted hello I think it's a
slight delay from the chamber okay hello
yes can you hear me yes we can hear you
can say right right okay thank you and
what I was gonna say was that you can
hear me chair okay and my concern is is
about their beautiful trees they're very
mature trees that you're going to knock
down to build these buildings I've got
great concerns about that I mean what
was what was your thoughts on that why
couldn't you have made the plans to work
wound the the trees that were already
there because that's part of you know
views that people want to see thank
thank you for your question so I
understand the sort of concerns around
that I think in terms of the location of
the trees we were very much in line if
they do follow the line of the existing
threshing ban so because we were looking
to respond in terms of the massing to
respond to to the existing buildings the
existing trees there were what we felt
was the the most appropriate location
for the new dwellings now we absolutely
understand that you know we're looking
to provide as much greenery and you know
soften as possible so as part of
proposals we are looking to provide new
trees within the the Correa's base
thank you any further questions
oh sorry counselor Foster Thank You
chair one question of God
there's a lot of a lot of the
explanation about restoration and
protection and preservation and a lot of
this a lot of this work these words
center around the conversion of the
existing building I'm aware of the
history of this application I'm new to
the planning committee so my question
would be how be given consideration
because this seems like there's two
applications in one here for brand-new
buildings on the Greenbelt
which is one question and the other one
which is being mixed in with it is the
restoration of the combination of an
existing building
have you made considerations playing to
separate applications into this because
we've got with us separate issues here
in two separate buildings thank you and
I think that's that's a very good
question and the reason for the drawing
application is and we've done that we've
done a lot of work throughout the
process of trying to understand this
discovered works was required to restore
these beautiful buildings and that is a
really substantial amount in piece of
work that needs to be done and
ultimately it sort of bears a
significant financial cost as well to to
the applicant
so as Murphy touched on as part of his
you know obviously sort of statement
today here there's a real significant
cost that involved in converting a
building of the nature of the fashion
brands to what is what is needed to
enable that preservation and conversion
of the confession bond is an element of
new build to offset the cost so we've
we've really worked hard to minimize
that and if you is to see the sort of
where we started on this journey in
terms of what the quantum of development
that we had at the pre-op stages it's
it's reduced significantly you know by
half and
where I think in terms of financial
viability we're on we're very much on
the limits in terms of offsetting the
cost of conversion versus the new build
elements and with you know as I said
we've worked hard to really minimize
that what what the scheme that you see
in today is you know an amount of
development that we've worked really
hard to achieve in terms of how it sits
comfortably on the site responds to the
existing buildings but also provides you
know enough of an offset to be able to
fund the work required to existing
buildings I hope I answered your
question
so we can't do one without the other
would be the shorter way of saying yeah
it's done the answer but that's not
really for me a consideration when
you're looking at this these are
obligations for me just that you have to
build for detached buildings on the
green roads so you can't so you can
actually convert this existing building
that doesn't stack up if you don't have
the money to do it us that's to be fair
that's your business and I'm looking at
those considerations in the papers and
it speaks in this way Bharati Oh on the
basis of the above policy context
officers are on the view that the
conversions of the existing buildings
within the application site would be in
compliance with the applicable
Greenville policies so that's one issue
that's for the conversion and true
you're aware of this and for the others
from the new buildings on this basis
offices consider that the developments
the hall towards the southern edge of
the Sai exception it carries on so that
you know we can't mix these two things
up not when it comes to Greenbelt policy
when if the answer is about all times
you can afford to fund them it's you
know for me there's not as much
irrelevant piece available these cleanup
considerations can you give me another
answer which would answer my point with
these Greenbelt considerations and not
to do with how you would fund it
yourself that's clear yeah I think it is
I think we've worked really hard to
minimize any potential impact on on the
Greenbelt and that's been achieved in a
variety of ways really the first thing
is in terms of the mass room which I've
spoken about already so I'm not going to
too much detail on but we've we've
brought up with with really limited how
how far south the existing of those
dwellings
so what we've done is we've worked
really hard to is to limit the eave
height so what we've done is with we've
actually got an internally you have
vaulted roof so you can you don't have a
flat ceiling of a vaulted roof and what
that means is that we can we can lower
the each site to minimize the effects on
the Greenbelt and the effect on on some
of the key views that I think that we'll
be able to pick up on further so by
designing the balanced in this way there
are much less in person on the green and
there each side is much less what that
does mean is that we've had to be very
considered in terms of how the spaces
are arranged internally but the the
outcome is is you know is a is a is
proposed proposed are in range of houses
that actually take much less area than
what they would have we you know
explored other options so we've worked
really hard to do that and I think you
know I think and certainly you know
inspecting internally those spaces would
be fantastic and would would enjoy
spectacular views out across the site
can you hear me yeah yes okay I just
want to write on what councillor Foster
was just saying it and just to kind of
increase a little bit more to help me a
little bit more so obviously you're
talking about impact with regards to the
Greenville and we're putting other
buildings within that which would
increase the amount of football it would
increase the amount of traffic going
into that area now obviously I've
listened to the applicants argument a
bit you know having farm traffic
previously but this would increase
residential traffic including visitors
would it not would you not consider that
that also impacts on that green Bell and
visually you know impact on how people
will see that that area if you're having
an increase in in residents coming up to
that area and increasing car numbers and
I know that it's talked about within the
report I got you know about parking and
things like that
however you will get visitors and
obviously you're going to have Walker's
a you know pass in the area would you
not consider that that will also detract
from the the openness and the making the
area look attractive and thank you for
your question and I I completely
understand and the considerations that
you've highlighted I think I think you
know we do have to be really careful in
terms of how that's handled and and how
that is developed through the planning
process I think as Matthew had had
expressed during system and he did you
know we had we do have to consider the
this application in the context of the
previous you sorts existing uses a
delivery and you know I think yes the
world would be an increase in car
traffic to to residential dwellings but
there will be you know there'll be less
traffic required and anticipated in
terms of the existing business you so we
sort of considered it in
of its you know its relative effects if
that makes sense in terms of the
existing business use versus the
increase in residential use but yeah I
understand
considerations and concerns but we can I
think we can we can work hard to dress
that carefully
Thank You councillor Barry that's are
moving on a bit to do with the design
side if you look at the policies that
Northeast Africa will be1 generally live
instance can you tell me who you feel
truly that this development actually
affects the character and appearance of
Australian area and does he contribute
towards providing a safe and secure
local environment because it's actually
states that the only time that we should
be getting planning permission in these
sorts of sites is it we could pull those
two off and add are just one really
thing to say whether you feel it goes on
well I do and we were you know with with
as part of the team we've we've sort of
tested each other rigorously throughout
this throughout the process in terms of
in terms of the design and you know to
speak openly you've got what we've done
is we've we've tried to work hard to
make sure that they Justin builders are
clear and distinct now it doesn't be
efficient with the comments that you you
know there may have been a preference
for us to do something that is that he's
more oriented to the existing buildings
but the challenge that that gives us is
that the the historic context is then
you know it does not then remain clear
indistinct I think our heritage
consultant that we're really keen to
hear from today you know raised a lot of
strong points that we had to address as
part of the design process so that
that's the that is absolutely the
approach we take and you know we we feel
as meif you said that I think what Mel
will go on to say is that you know we
really believe that this is and is the
right thing and it's been a really
thorough process for us and you know
it's been a great scheme I've loved
working on this effort you know in it
and enjoyed every minute and we've had
to take a view and it's been our
approach to ensure that the historic
context is preserved and that allows to
speak for itself by remaining clear and
distinct
thank you nikki is Mel Morris I believe
we do have mal Morris in the in the
meeting room chair now are you so oh I
beg your pardon I don't have my
statement in front of me I've had to
move location um can I have that read
out or the romaine read out is that
possible because I have had to move I
think that's possible chair I think the
point which you've finished on just bear
with me a second
you
where you were talking about the two
main parameters I think at that point
the feed broke so should I start from
that point yes please
okay and the text reads the two main
parameters and constraints for the new
developments which I identified word as
follows
warn you respect important views within
and of the conservation area and how it
is appreciated
these were accepted by the planning
authorities conservation adviser and to
to enable the original cluster of
historic buildings to stand out as a
distinct group not to ape them or copy
their details or kruger core create
confusion by adding extensions and
diluting their character these are sound
conservation principles accepted by the
conservation advisor and have been
carefully observed by the architect the
development is aspires to the highest
standards of design there are key areas
where the planning consultant and myself
have had an input into the design
including the orientation of buildings
the clustering and massing of the
development the proportion of stone to
metal cladding the color of the cladding
and then brackets advised on softer gray
so that this would read better than the
black against the sky the use of natural
surfacing materials which
the result is a very well considered and
thoughtful development which is
responded to its local context yes the
new development is can territory but I
believe is it that it is a good thing
the use of metal cladding is appropriate
it is a material which can already be
found on site in the form of a Dutch
bond which is a form of late 19th
century traditional farm building so as
appropriate in its context the scheme
should be considered as a whole it
offers the exemplary conservation
practice the rescue of a 17th century
threshing barn and it's sensitive to its
context thank you for your time thank
you are you able to take any questions
yes I okay are there any
first yes many members can say David
Hancock's indicating his thank you chair
it's just much to pick up on on some of
the councillor foster raised earlier
which you've really touched upon very
well kind of touched upon in your
comments there and they are really two
very different things we're talking
about a restoration project and we're
talking about a new build and I'll be
completely honest as I've been going
through this we've got the restoration
project is fine and I would approve that
without any issue at all everything
follows through I'm just not seeing how
the extra buildings are tying in with
appropriate green develop development
and the problem the father these two
along together means that I'm really
struggle to see how I can fit the policy
in approving it and I know our officers
have kind of made one recommendation one
way or nothing that you've said there
the fact that you're making a
contemporary which I respect you Musa I
don't job anything that you're saying
you're almost making it not fit and
that's the key the key constant that I
have here and it really isn't everything
that you're saying is to try make it fit
fit the Heritage but it just doesn't
now if I can respond to scheme the
topography is a challenge and the
topography is definitely a challenge and
when we looked at where we could put new
development on the site
we are tightly constrained by by the
land form and by the nature of the
relationship with the existing buildings
so we had we looked at I think about
half a dozen iterations of the form and
the scale and the relationship and the
clustering of the housing thing and it
was decided that it was better to
distance it from the farmhouse and
better to distance it from the existing
group now once you've made these
decisions we're looking at preserving
the views we are looking at essentially
what is it's about architectural style
and design and whether you think it fits
or is appropriate in that setting and I
think it is difficult and it is it's not
an easy sight but it is because of the
topography that the buildings rise up
the slope and that is perhaps what
people are concerned about my my answer
is what we have done everything we can
to soften the impact by reducing the
scale of the two two-story elements if
we were to if Alex was to be asked to to
design something of a lower scale you
would have something which would be much
more sprawling in effect and I thought
that the the relationship between the
semi detached buildings which sit
alongside each other but they they
fragmented so that they actually
staggered on plan and the same with the
the other part of their development we
have broken it up we have tried to
reduce the impact and we've tried to do
that by using the softer materials
I think the effects going to be the same
if it's in a stone and similar and
perhaps even more impact and if than the
effect we've got now with this riveting
metal cladding because the cladding
brings the walls and the roof together
it is perhaps a matter of maybe a matter
of personal taste but there are many
examples where you have metal cladding
on agricultural buildings and on new
development in that in this context in
the whole of Derbyshire you do find
these sort of these sorts of stylistic
juxtapositions for want of a better
phrase hope that answers it a little
Thank You chair he's following along the
same lines that are put to Ashley Turner
and other members have brought up you
say at the end of your statement that
the scheme should be considered as a
whole and when I put that question about
looking at it being two separate
applications to actually Turner the
anguish the answer he gave me was a
financial one I understood the answer
and I'd last thought the same question
to you and if you could answer it from a
heritage perspective because obviously
that's your area speciality why should
it be considered as a whole from a
heritage aspect
thank you and from a heritage aspect I'm
I look at the totality of what we've got
now and what we have now is a large
sprawling development of livery type
livery stables and inappropriate
bungalow a Dutch barn which you know it
is an agricultural building so it's not
this will cause me an offence as it is
but looking at all of the quantum of
existing modern development which is a
lot of breeze block large liveries of
area area men ours which is quite a
quite a disk are
all of that is part of the big picture
and this is what I mean by looking it at
it holistically we are losing that we
are going to be exposing the flank wall
of the threshing barn you will
appreciate that in the scheme as part of
how it was always intended to be seen as
you approach it from the footpath
so holistically we're looking at three
things we're looking at the the removal
of the existing development which is
inappropriate new you build and we're
looking at the conversion and altogether
that's where - I mean about taking on
board everything you've got to look at
the whole picture rather than sort of
focus entirely on the new build element
does that answer your question
it is an answer to my question when I
consider what you mentioned in the Dutch
barn the bungalow and the sprawl of
livery buildings that to me is what I
see of Derbyshire and the Greenbelt
that's what I see is a typical view and
that you can see in every small village
around around northeast so a holistic is
seeking for new metal clad buildings on
the Greenbelt to me my view is that have
been less holistic way you've been less
in keeping than a duck farm bundle on
the sprawl of Liberty buildings that's
someone that you but thanks for answer
thank you are there any further
questions no then the next part of the
meeting will begin to have any questions
put to the planning officers but one
thing I would ask you to do is to just
focus on getting clarity from any points
that you look sure about and then once
we've done
chair it's Chet and Paula jeez we lost
your audio them for a moment would you
mind just going back
it was happy about the discussion on the
application for that reason I would ask
that if we could actually wait until we
lose as feel
baby yeah it's quite runny because of
delay company might put forward until
the ends that have a deep but their
views across is everyone happy with that
the unsent know something is up
sorry chair I think much of that was
lost would you be able to repeat the
reasoning fun by
I reach I kept breaking up then I
couldn't hear all of what you said
Madame sherry you keep breaking up
you
sorry chilly I didn't hear any of the
conversation from the beginning of when
you start to speak basically what it was
is the moving on soon
okay I'll start from the front so we're
now moving on to where it's questions to
the planning officers now some reader
okay so I just want to say you all hear
me
so track just to the phone in offices
obviously we I just wanted to get some
clarification and the issues around
traffic and and the parking issue so
obviously in the report and on page 23
it talks about two years ago a car Court
was refused planning permission is same
property because of insufficient parking
the development would not have provided
adequate off-street parking spaces for
for up to five households that was only
two years ago and then there was
obviously in the same on the same page
highway safety concerns brought that you
know it just talked about increased
vehicle movement which would exactly
exacerbate an existing problem they're
also moving throughout the whole and she
it was raised more and more concerns
about amended schemes that have failed
to address the issues around adequate
parking and highways obviously brought
up concerns relating to access and
parking arrangements you move through
the whole of the report again for this
current application and as concerns
obviously around the footpath which I
I'm a bit concerned that and I'm still
not getting the sense that this has been
addressed and then though Alex was
speaking earlier and he said he would be
seeking to address this issue but for
the determining this today I'm concerned
that not enough has kind of been brought
forward in terms of how that is going to
be addressed and so for me and I know
that officers are saying that they don't
feel that they
an effect of traffic is is severe enough
to consider that but actually when you
look at the history of this side and
considering that we've had applications
in the past refused on these grounds
when you come to it now and you look at
the concerns that all the objectors are
bringing with regards to very narrow
lanes you've got the ward member also
saying that traffic it will be very
difficult vehicles moving around that
site would be very difficult for them to
go down the lane passing each other
listen to everything that everyone has
got say so and just asking officers can
you clarify how that impact has been
resolved from two years ago when the
application was refused because of that
too now
sheriff canceled readers made a number
of points down I'm not some familiar
necessarily with the issue of the
carport although I'm just trying to find
that in terms of the history to it but
what I will do first of all if I may
chose is discuss the basic and traffic
issue that accounts the readers raised
now in terms of this application alone
the highway authority have not objected
the issue of comings and goings as
vehicles what they raised sooner there
was the actual on side width of the
access and also the level of car parking
and officers sure members will have seen
could address those issues in terms of
how we we see them but fundamentally
that I were thority not saying that the
amount of traffic that would use the
site would be harmful and I'm bearing in
mind that there is an extant use for
both livery and a single dwelling
already for the site they're saying is
there are insight issues and what the
awfully well resulting is actually a
management alongside matters so those
new residents who will occupy the site I
come to manage their comings and goings
if there is conflict and also sort out
the parking if there is a problem on the
site and there is a very small
deficiency of what you would normally
look for for interment of this nature
just in terms of the the general comings
and goings there are five new dwellings
proposed notwithstanding the extang use
on the site and the normal rule of thumb
is that would result in six car per car
movement per day resulting in 30 over a
24-hour period of which 15 percent in
normal in the peat which is round about
a five so you're looking at between one
movement every 15 to 12 minutes and this
officer as far as officers are concerned
that isn't so significant as it would
adversely impact on highway safety just
in terms of the footpath if I'm a chair
when we were on site in March and as we
discussed yesterday the issue
of the footpath and currently it runs
through the site and there is a style
and while two styles and a gate that
allow access through the side to the
footpath that then goes Southwest into
the North or Valley and so there is a
line of a footpath and as we heard
earlier and the current line of the
footpath actually goes through one of
this story buildings so there's clearly
an issue there but again as far as
officers are concerned there is no
reason why the existing right-of-way
whether it be the appropriate and proper
right away couldn't be retained and used
and modified going forward so there is
ways of doing that and Jim could perhaps
advise on that issue and just going back
to be the carport and be sure I've just
managed to find some details chair on
that and and that was an application
that was considered back in 2017 and the
council did take a viewer I believe that
the impact of the carport was
detrimental highway safety for the
reasons that were set out in the
decision notice members need to take
that into account however ultimately
they need to judge this application on
its merits and whether in terms of
comings and goings of vehicles or
highway safety there is an issue with
regards to that but the matter centered
on the carport scale location prominent
position rather than one of highway
safety in terms and that that issue was
also wasn't in terms of Highway Safety
that carport was refused it was in terms
of impact on conservation area
throughout the planning reasons and I
hope that that helps chair and assist
casually reader
Thank You counsel the berry then I've
got counts that are teaching councillor
Foster
Thank You Adrian I'm struggling with the
results that the officers have come up
with and especially around the fact that
you're saying there are very special
circumstances in relation to the
retention and the repair of the bombs
I've gone through all the policies and
I've been reading them through and
through and it's not as I can see I
can't I cannot find a reason how we can
possibly pass this application if you
look just at h3 in itself it states that
we should only be granted for housing
development our sanity final settlement
development limits in father forced with
one or more of the following categories
and if you could be is a female
development in the country tonight which
can be shown to be necessary for the
operation of agricultural which this
isn't the cows will seem to negotiate
what I'll say this isn't to do
agriculture so it's not going to affect
battle like that dwellings finally the
number of dwellings would not be
increased and any result employer would
not be materially larger these are for
brownian properties we've got one that's
been retained which is the threshing are
all running property some are struggling
to see when we where we think with that
and again through the GS malting five
thousand seven you read through the
promoter said but it should be accepted
or not they supplicate doesn't fall
within it and may the renovation of the
this small advance which are going to be
used on Sylvie which could be anything
and it depends on whether the people in
the new houses want these artillery
bombs but they're going to be a useful I
mean I can't see where the special
circumstances are strong you know just
saying that oh yeah we can build a brand
new houses where the material is
unsuitable and you know it's so the size
of the buildings are far too big and on
one part a
says about the doctors of similar size
is if you're replacing it well these are
huge into the bottom so that the
materials in size the quantity are they
and the fact that you know it would be
like pollution in that area that isn't
very existing like and also the effect
that it will have as you walk around
that area because they will stand out
that so I'm not sure how you can only
rule those and the policies that we have
eaten blood Spurs with special
circumstances so can you tell me how
that special circumstance on the bomb
outweighs the the effect it's going to
have on the area and the green space and
market and being in a spring situation
but that is the note chair that members
need to take a view on this afternoon
just and back to the the planning
argument if I may at the end but I would
ask members to be wary of how much
weight they do place on certainly policy
h3 and to a lesser extent policy gs2
because at various appeals policy h3 has
been deemed by planning inspectors to
not be in accordance with the EMP PF and
so have carry very limited weight in
terms of GS to it is in general
conformity with the MVP F but it doesn't
mirror it entirely so and that's why
we've gone to such lengths within the
report to discuss the wording of the MVP
F which probably in there certainly in
the case of and the principle of
development that is the primary
consideration however chair
fundamentally and officers I don't
believe that Doug the issue of the
proposal within the green belt at all
we've set out very clearly the issued in
respect of green belt policy and as
counsel Foster amongst others have said
the conversion of buildings within green
belt to amongst other uses the
residential use would be in conformity
with and your own policies and also the
MPP F
is the issue of the four new dwelling
houses which as officers we conclude and
accept is in appropriate development
particularly as there will be a visual
impact on the Greenbelt
however chair it is our planning
judgment that in this case because the
benefits that are brought about in terms
of the renovation and retention of the
buildings of character on the site in
the opinion of officers that does
represent in this case that very special
circumstances to justify the scheme
members need to take that into account
but the debate that you've been having
this afternoon demonstrates that is
planning judgment which you will need to
take a view on and so it's clearly set
out in the report I believe chair why
officers have come to the conclusion
that we have members need to go through
the same and thought process development
in the Greenbelt is it appropriate or
inappropriate like members from the
debate they having clearly accent that
it would normally be an appropriate
development therefore to justify it and
overcome any on the Greenbelt you need
to consider whether there are any very
very special circumstances and in the
report chair we've set our wires
officers we believe they are members
need to take that self same and thought
process and consider what the conclusion
is I just would like two dimensional so
I think counts the Barry mention this
book some of the words you used in
Casselberry I lost I'm afraid but I
think you mentioned this you do need
also a special regard to the location of
the site within the conservation area
third various speakers talked about that
this afternoon
you need to have special regards that
and with the issue of the conservation
area you need consider if there is harm
to the conservation area and as officers
again we conclude that there is public
benefits that come with the renovation
of the bills again outweigh that harm so
that's the the conclusion that we've
come to do on those those planning
issues chair I do have that that helps
and cows the burying of the members but
of course happily you take more
questions and trample and advice as
necessary
Thank You counselor Armitage Thank You
chair can you hear me hello yes okay
this is an amended app application there
were lots of things which were brought
to the applicants attention last time
has he done anything did you advise him
what he should have done
and as he absolutely done anything
because as far as I can see it's exactly
the same thing the same application that
we had last time and he's done nothing
to justify any of his any of the
problems of which we saw last time
would you agree Sharon on that point
again as you heard earlier on the
application has come back on altered for
that which you you considered back in
March
that is the applicants and discretion me
it's entitled to do that you need to
consider the application on its merits
the fact that he chose not to alter the
scheme doesn't mean that it's
necessarily unacceptable therefore you
need to consider the scheme on its
merits and not the fact that you made
certain points in March and the
applicant has chosen not to amend the
scheme the fact that there wasn't
supposed to respond to that wouldn't in
itself be sufficient to and resist the
application you need to consider it on
its planning marys as I've just
discussed with cows the barre
in could I come back again chair yes
right
Indian PPF it's parallel 143
it says about inappropriate development
in the Greenbelt so this got out special
circumstances and I'm sorry I can't see
any special circumstances here it's in a
conservation area you know you've got to
look at it with the materials I mean
this metal black metal cladding on an in
an elevated position I mean just stick
out like a carbon would you agree on
that the visual impact is just not in
keeping with the area again yet chair
just to try and help councillor Armitage
oh I don't think officers have that
issue I the chair that's clear set out
in the report that as cancer Armitage
mentions the MV P F is clear your own
policies are clear that in your probity
that developed is by definition of
agreement and should not be proved
except in very special circumstances
that's the line that officers have taken
in our report officers have just
concluded that we believe there is very
special circumstances for the reasons
that we discussed and the benefits that
the scheme would bring with it members
need to go through that self same
thought process and you need to George
whether you believe what's been put
forward there's a very special
circumstance is justifies granting
permission for what is otherwise and
mostly an appropriate development
getting back to what councillor Foster
said earlier on and officers to chair
discussed in our report the issue about
the location of the new houses yes they
will be on an elevated part to the site
overlooking the valley and officers
conclude that there would be a visual
impact so so certainly we're not seeking
to say that there aren't those impacts
what we are saying in our opinion is
that there are very special
circumstances and
need to consider whether you agree with
officers in this case or whether you
don't but you do need to go through that
self same thought process
greenbelt inappropriate or not
development if it is inappropriate on a
very special circumstances
so the thought process the same chair
members may come to a different
conclusion that is a perfectly
reasonable planning and judgment to take
providing you can evidence it and you
have reason to do so but you need to go
through that cell same process
Thank You chair I've got two questions
I'm happy to come back a later time on
the on the traffic issue which is what
we will cover in earlier so I can ask
the afterwards but firstly I'd like to
concentrate on this sin issue which
Adrienne's can explain two or three
times now and when we look at the
conclusions on page it does explain what
age in speaking about and he sees a
distinct farm group the list and
substantial harm caused by the messiness
killed the new buildings is considered
to be outweighed by the public benefits
arising by way of saving it's important
who studied fondant and securing an
optimal values this understand and it's
clear so we understand that this then
five new building two detrimental their
officers and wait this against the
public benefits arising by saving this
important of a historic farmers so when
you look at what how this will affect
residents how it will affect and the
overall look of the green belts and what
I've countryside will look like obvious
is what they've done is they've
considered he's for new buildings I'm
considered a price worth paying for the
restoration and this saving this
historic farm group now I heard pull the
poem the second I heard this and these
are the exceptional circumstances what
I'd like a proper definition before I
decide in my mind which radio is the
right way to go on this issue
I'd like a proper definition and
explanation by Adrian or any other
officer what exactly it and how much
weight we can put to these public
benefits so it's accepted there are
public benefits in presenting this
historic four hundred but how great are
they
and it's that is why I'd like to explore
that will decide the scale thank you and
that is
the Nagas at the judgment chair that
members are being asked to to make this
afternoon can't unfortunately tell
members how much weight to place on
those benefits as outlined to officers
and I am of the view that there aren't
any other public benefits other than the
retention and renovation of an historic
group of farm buildings within a
conservation area that is the judgment
that the decision maker ie planning
committee this afternoon need to
consider chair if this were left to an
officer delegated decision officers
would conclude those public benefits in
terms of the renovation and restoration
of those buildings in a group called
outweigh the other issues and the same
goes and this case the Fosters mentioned
in speaking this afternoon about the
green belt issues and it's the self same
benefits that officers believe outweigh
the harm to the green belt and be and
less versus less and substantial harm at
the conservation area but I can't
unfortunately give a definition of what
and probably then pits may or may not be
for members to consider nor indeed how
much weight you should put on any
particular issue for members all I can
tell you is officers have given them
significant weight in this instance but
it is for you as the decision makers
planning committee to place a program
weight on them and weigh them therefore
in the planning balance yeah sure but
thank you for if you can just come back
on that issue I don't have any public
benefit share you know I understand that
to weigh them I'd love to be told that
in well not mean me by doing such we
told that and knew how to waive them but
I need to know what the public benefits
are we can't just say this public
benefits and I don't need at least
stating and what's written and it's not
only benefit our to know how much weight
Vaman thank you the public benefits
chair are the restoration and renovation
of historical buildings within the
conservation area
I'm sorry that's that's still not the
loo benefits it's just a statement Jeff
and I try and help further but and
officers consider that the benefits to
the it's it's a and public interest
benefit to preserve retain and renovate
buildings within the conservation area
in this context that is the benefit to
the wider public that officers have
weighed in this instance
I just thank you can I just add that
here what accounts to Fosters then and
also here what Adrian is advising I
don't think officers can say any more
about the aspects of community or public
benefits if members have a different
view on that they're perfectly entitled
to take that view and put that into the
balance of the decision-making um you
know I don't think we've got anything
more than we can really add to what
agent has already said
okay thank you counselor foster you came
back you had two parts of the question
question but it came from earlier chair
with your permission it's about it's a
question twittering about the County
Council's comments are you able to take
that question yes Cheryl I'll seek help
if I can of course Thank You chair
appreciate it
we know those those accepted concerns
about the visibility around the access
road and my own view of this so far is
that the increasing traffic without
accumulative negative impact on the area
and there's also safety concerns
regarding the junction Hawkins plain
bill thought lane but Pross have like
some exact comments on what Derbyshire
County Council have said Davies issues
as Adrienne said earlier about concerns
relating to the proposed access and also
the parking arrangements now we know in
here reading the papers that been
commented on by district officers so the
district officers have made comments on
what the highway engineers that dog sure
council council has said what lack to
know is update on any conditions or
introduce them control measures or a bit
brought into play that would affect the
comments or the issues raised by the
highway engineer has been relating to
the proposed access and parking area so
of what our officers thought to say
regarding their comments though that's
clear Carol I've come back hopefully
your help counts the foster on those
points and and I'm sure : all all and
come in if I've got this wrong but the
highway authority have not raised any
issue with regards to the access onto
the primary highway network so the
photographs that we saw earlier of the
actual access onto the primary I win
they've not raised any issues with what
they have did raise concerns about is
the width of the access track inside the
site which is naturally constrained by
the wall and the other buildings and
what the Highway Authority was saying is
they would want that at five meters
width which if they did that would have
a detrimental impact on a number of the
soaring buildings which I'm part of the
reason for the application is to retain
and renovate those they also raised
concern about the parking on site and as
I mentioned earlier that is below the
levels and the standards that you would
normally look to achieve on on a site
switch because this the view that
officers have taken on that chair is
that they are on site issues and they
don't affect the wider highway network
or wider highway safety outside the site
and so the only impact of them will be
on those who choose to live on the site
and as far as officers are concerned
that would be something that would be
managed by those who live on the site
and because of the distance from the
site entrance to the houses would not in
my view be something that would spill
out onto the highway network and affect
others in the vicinity of the site so in
weighing that officers have taken the
view that there isn't an adverse impact
on a nun except when packed and highway
safety and that the residual or
cumulative impact which I discussed
earlier on in terms of traffic movement
would not impact on the road network as
a severe level that's that's our view
chairs so and we've taken the views of
how Authority looked at them and taken
the view that they are very localized if
at all and cannot be said turbine on etc
impact on highway safety or have a
residual cumulative impact that would be
severe I hope that's how
you
okay any further questions Thank You
counsel it egde yes
this application is egg duck as I've
said before exactly the same as far as
I'm concerned it's inappropriate
development in the green belt it if we
look at paragraph 143 of the MPP F it
there are no as far as I can see special
circumstances for it's in a conservation
only area and there'll be a negative
impact on landscape problems with the
hope the road safety aspect not enough
parking spaces and mobility problems but
as far as the I'm concerned they seem to
think it's okay but we've had this
argument with highways before so but in
conclusion I know that we've got
officers as a recommendation and we
should turn this application down a lot
so second that we haven't got to that
did you want to say anything I counselor
Hancock's left the room at Jerry's got
one further question before we move the
motion is just the verification period
we're talking about the bombs being
repaired
no bombs are listed in any way shape or
form
that's that's correct yes and if I may
just before members take the vote my my
suggestion chair if and I nope then the
motion that's been then moved by
Councillor Armitage chair just if I can
be clear first of all on the reasons I
think canister Armitage is saying that
Barry it's unacceptable developed in the
green belt and there are no sufficiently
very special circumstances outweighing
the harm to the green belt he's also
saying I believe that the development
fails to protect and respect the current
appearance of the area the reason such
as materials scaled massing location of
the new dwellings and far any chair and
I think I'm correct in this case aunty
is also saying for those the same
reasons the impact of the realms is
unacceptable in the conservation area
but I'm not hearing though chair is the
casualty and wanting to refuse the
application on the basis of highway
issues and I would I would advise that
is the correct approach if members stand
do you intend to go down the the Reid
and the path that refusing the
application just finally chair and to
try and assist members if it's okay with
yourself and counts the Barry if that
motion is passed I suggest that the
final wording of the reasons for refusal
would be delegated to officers in
consultation with yourself and counselor
battery thank you sure appreciate that
good out with the permission of the
council Armitage can we make sure that
we include the traffic issue so the
traffic issue is included in this as
Adrienne's just said but also eight
point three to five on page 30 but it
says the new buildings outweighed by the
public benefits coming out back half
court employees public benefits do in my
view do not outweigh now the permission
of counsel Armitage it has to look at
that huh can we make sure that the
public benefits do not
the harm caused by the massive scale of
the new buildings so is that clear well
sir thank you second dimension good
October again just on on the question of
highways if you were to go to appeal the
fact that the highways people have come
out in favor of the application I think
it will it will be unsafe to use the
highways and the road safety aspect as a
reason and I think Adrian could advise
on that I accept longitude okay just I
can be clear chair just the putting that
has the foster made in terms of both the
agreement of reason and a conservation
area reason and it would be my intention
chair to add in the issue that any
public benefits or very special
circumstances in case of Greenbelt way
the the harm that's caused but just in
so are we can be absolutely clear chair
I'm hearing that cancer problem which is
about the foster don't want the motion
to include issues relating down by the
way safe to your traffic just took me
absolutely clear on that chair there
would be three reasons or wording
associated with three reasons Greenbelt
harm harm to be the wider landscape in
terms of the scale massing materials
that are proposed and also harm to the
conservation area but just those issues
and not and issues relating to highways
parking or traffic yes I agree with them
Adrienne's covered all the additional
points I had to me thank you everyone
understand the grounds for why we're
going to perhaps it would just be useful
if we just actually repeat that again
sure so the motion is to reject officer
recommendations on the grounds of I
think a genius was it in terms of the
harm to the Greenbelt
the materials issue and developments
within the conservation area along the
lines which is to be discussed with the
final sort of wording actually to be
agreed in consultation with yourself and
councillor Perry I got that right there
Adrian that's bright to have enough I
think in hopefully a casualty who cares
the foster will look like except that by
going through cows the roof and accounts
the Barry that we should secure the the
wishes of the the committee should the
vote and go in that direction
so they're both before us is to reject
the applications bullabbai accounts are
on teach seconded by Mark Costas so we
need to go to the full bone birthing
mental membership yep and I think we're
doing this by roll call early that's
right and I'll be handled by the
facilitator chair Thank You chef so I'm
going to do a roll call vote
so members could turn on their cameras
at this point and just answer for
against or abstain and that's for
rejecting the application that's the
William Armitage cancer Jane Barry how's
that Jane Barry now - Andrew Cooper Oh
sir
that's the mode pox
now some Oh pots no unites no sorry
about that
for Allen Powell
Oh Elsa Tracy Mita
Oh
now so Jacqueline Bridgeway for Cathy
baths full and cancer Diana Ross
you'll notice that counselor at Carol
Huckabee wasn't called in that roll call
I understood the counselor Carol
Huckabee was not voting on this item is
that correct no it isn't I'm not voting
no I'm not voting on the next one but
I'm certainly voting on this one I see
you because it's a tis for a councilor
Huckabee you actually spoke against the
application so on that basis you would
not normally be expected to those on
this okay yes so think on that basis
councilor who could be would not be part
of the voucher so on that basis chair
you've received ten votes for reduction
of the application
thank you thank you everybody I know
it's taken up a bit longer than we
anticipated but thank you for your
patience it's unjust election to be
closed okay so just to be absolutely
clear for those watching sure that the
motion has passed Thank You chair
yeah thank you taken part believing and
members are we going to have a comfort
break before we move on to the next
application yes please say about 10
minutes chair okay you're okay
for the life eat
okay welcome back everybody thank your
patience and do you want to go through a
road call again or is it okay that we
are standing as before I can just
confirm chairs are in the meeting room
we have counselor
William artitude William Armitage
counselor Jayne Barry
Andrew Cooper Mark Foster mo Potts Carol
Huckabee Allen pal Tracy reader
Jackie Ridgeway Kathy brows and yourself
chair Dianna Roy mrs. R as the previous
meeting and the head of planning in the
meeting room as well as the planning
manager Adrienne Kirkham and the
governance team to support the meeting
thank you
and so the first item second item on the
agenda so ready is the planning
application which is any d4 woodstove
2000 one eight by the scale homes field
making look and would like to take a
suit presentation yes thank you chair
again just ahead of going through the
presentation just to refer members to
the lake comments report that was sent
out yesterday
and also brief introduction chair just
to explain that this application seeks
the construction of a building to be
used as a scout hood although the
supporting information to suggest that
it would also be used for other purposes
it would measure approximately 90 meters
by 40 meters with an overall height of
six point seven meters comprising
accommodation of a whole Lobby kitchen
toilets back room and storerooms with
storage above
in addition that chair will be sort of
stone with dark gray standing seen zinc
roofing it's also proposed chair to
create a car park to serve the building
and also the area around the building
would be used to service the hot
the previous application share this site
is located in the Greenbelt and also
within a with a different conservation
area the homes for conservation area in
this case but also in this instance the
proposed building is within the setting
of the grade 2 listed church absence
rhythms and we'll see some photographs
of that in a second
in this instance chair and officers
conclude the building is in appropriate
development in the Greenbelt who fails
to fill any of the exceptions to that
general policy position although the
applicant does in the submitted
statements allude to a different view
and commuting that is used to support
outdoor and sport our assay offices take
a different view chair and concluding
it's an appropriate development officers
also conclude chair the due to the
building size and location it would have
significant visual harm on the openness
of the Greenbelt as the applicant seeks
to set out that there are very special
circumstances justifying approval of
this scheme and exceptions those
Greenbelt restrictions officers
concludes in this case they aren't
sufficient to offset the harm that would
be caused to commune belt and
additionally she understood my members
that the committee need to pay special
regard to the site's location within the
conservation area but also in this case
to the setting of Swithin's Church
offers us to conclude chair that the
introduction of this functional building
to the site would fail to preserve the
conservation area or the setting of the
listed church just on technical issues
chair and officers don't believe there
are any technical or amenity issues that
would justify on their own refused in
the application in conclusion chair
officers don't consider there are very
special circumstances justified student
in a green belt and that it would have
failed to protect the valued heritage
assets as I've outlined accordingly
officers recommend that the application
is refused just on one point if I'm a
chair further to the virtual site visit
we only talked yesterday whereas the
Barry and I discussed the location of
since women's church I did incorrectly
say yesterday chair that the church was
located within the settlement limits of
homes field it's not chaired outside
those limits and is within the Greenbelt
just if
Nikki's able to help with the
presentation she'll just go through the
slides that have been
prepared
just go through to the next one
Nikki please the application site Jer is
the site is roughly in n shape and sorry
we can't see the slides on us free does
that go for all members chair I'm not
sure we're in the chamber so I can see
the lovely I can see them okay yeah I
just I can see them okay I'm just gonna
stop screen sharing just for a moment
just resolve that for you
the slides are going on the live feed so
it must be something that's not working
currently in the chamber will organize
some on-site support and for you are you
if I try and screen show now could you
confirm that you can see it should be
active in a moment it's that better
chair no all we've got is bassist do you
just want to talk us through I mean the
counts Barry and I have seen it so
unless there's anything different to
that we requite happy to just talk this
through
Adrian okay I'll carry on sheriff you
yeah who was that and Ricky tacky with
that jet and the other members chair can
see on the the screen roughly an N Shake
in the middle of there sly which
identifies the application site on the
right hand bottom line of that end there
is a slightly lighter shade that's the
existing church carpark chair and just
above there then before the end of the
cemetery where the the field lines out
that would be the area where the car
part would be formed but also there Jen
just and as the field would open out
that is where the new building is
proposed so if the building is proposed
next door to the existing car park but
beyond there some distance and beyond
and the other fields chair the ones that
and identified in the application start
to be using the association of the scout
hood Thank You Nicki and this shows that
in more detail the chair the the site is
I'm showing an sorry of the screen is
showing the application site so there's
the existing Church car park
in an area that's identified as Scout
car park and then the rectangular and
blob is the location of the building
itself and field one and two within the
application site and as I say the site
and is
within the conservation area and the
c-shaped is building just to the bottom
right of that leg of the N is since
women's church thanks Nikki
in more detail chair the the building is
now being shown on the screen it's the
rectangular shape at the head of the
that's the top third of the this slide
and since Whitman's church in this
instance is just to the bottom right of
that slide so slightly in the
conservation area since women's church a
Grade II listed building thanks Nikki
just some details of the the structure
chair in this instance and as with the
previous application the building would
be stone and modular roofing so the
roofing would be of as I mentioned in
the the opening it would be the
sheathing that is identified as I think
it's it's defined as standing seam so
it's a modular roof with and some
elements that are raised above that so
creating some scenes within it thanks
Nikki I'm just going to go into the
other two elevations now that's just go
back oh yeah briefly Nikki thank you the
elevation the top is the east elevation
which would overlook the fields to the
east and the Northeast North elevation
clearly facing north is blank if you see
the photographs Nikki please the first
one that shows the existing access into
the church carpark so the existing
carpark there and the site itself is
beyond the hedge that you can see in the
middle distance this slide identifies
the wall on the right hand side is the
kickback that dad mentioned where the
field lines out
so whether photographer is is part of
the post carpark and then if you just go
to the next one make you be the
photographer pounds round so you can
just see there and kick back there so
the area in the foreground is where the
car part would be the area where that
crease in the wall opens out that's
where the building would be located and
beyond
you can just see I think it's bungalow
bungalow farm and which is the building
in the distance just beyond the
application site boundary if you pan
around Nikki you should see more of the
western boundary then if you pan around
again please looking back the area
that's in the foreground will be the car
part to the photographer's now taking
the picture from the location of the
proposed building the foreground would
be the car part and then you can just
see the blue car in the middle of the
slide that's a car parked in the
existing carpark and then you can make
out now the some Swimming's church-tower
and hence the officer conclusion that
the building would have any
pants on the setting of that listed
building
thanks Nikki next one they're just wider
shots this now looks back towards the
application site to that wall on the
left hand side that returns now that's
the crease I've kept on referring to so
the building would be on the middle
right of this shot so roughly way you
can see that that house which is beyond
the site and across the lane but the
building would be in that location but
on the field in the foreground so the
building from whether photographers
would actually and take over the view of
that building and remove it from shots
building would be their car park on the
left and just the final one please
thank you that's the same shot but that
shows through that western boundary
across the lane that's one of the
dwellings it's located across the cross
this is tombi and in the papers is
referred to as host field hall cottage
and that's that's the presentation
included care applique questions later
thank you and can we move on to the
first speak up and down as Nick we the
chair of the parish council
so it's Barry we'd actually I'm chairman
of home for Parish Council
you've got three minutes this tweet
thank you as you appreciate I'm speaking
on behalf of the Parish Council which
I've been chairman for the last 40 years
now as a former cub and King Scout
myself and like so many parishioners who
have supported this application
including our local district councillor
Kara Huckabee and our MP Lee Rowley all
know of the benefits from being a member
of the third home Steele Scouts which
was formed by the vicar of our church in
1957 and who became the first Scout
leader Thomas Hill has a small primary
school any acres which is a very
important serving now looked young
people and to complement this it would
be ideal to welcome back to our village
the Scout rule the Scout could continue
to thrive with over 110 members and a
current waiting list in 2008 their
accommodation was sold by the village
church - from their new modern church
hall in order to retain the Scout group
they were forced to seek a temporary
move out of the village and share with
five other scout groups at rakes Lane in
drum field some two and a half miles
outside our village these premises have
a limited lifespan with no disable
access or toilets all internal and
external equipment equipment is a
currently housed in metal containers the
parish council had for the last 12 years
been looking for a suitable site to
build a new Scout switch in the village
which can enjoy an adjacent feel for
outdoor sports and recreation which in
today's world is of great importance you
can understand how excited the Parish
Council which were really Stu the Scout
group on the proposed site in the stents
of the village the site is accessible by
foot from the adjacent housing estates
and enjoys use of the existing village
hall and Church car parking the site is
also adjacent the existing electric
ghasts and drainage services and of
course close to the church the
traditional
scalp and guide parades the building is
sited well away from historic buildings
and a detailed professional survey and
report by Anderson tree care has
established at the existing the chiller
hedge and trees are retained clear of
any root protection to give an
established screening to the proposed
building it is noted that contents has
been recently granted on appeal within
30 seconds remains three new dwellings
access from Park Avenue if we now feel
can again provide a scout and
recreational field that will allow
children to lead active community
spiritual happy lives filled with fun
friendship and adventure this surely
will be a positive influence and
something we must strive to achieve in
light of the present push for children
to be engaged in positive pursuits and
the consequence of the closing of youth
clubs we respect the request a stream in
his chair where the very basic will meet
with government objectives for many
years to come thank you thank you are
there any questions to mr. Wade
counselor foster ever thank you sure
counsel foster here a question for
counsel wheat is the for the maintenance
of this is that currently at Holmes
field staff group if there is how many
members where is it currently is the
replay there 110 current members and
they are currently how's Rachel aid in
drom field
yeah but right so that's so that's
specifically a unskilled stamp rude meet
three weeks late yeah and you said
there's no disabled access there I know
near at the viscosity break scam and
that desert disabled I would
sorry chair just from that same point
this is a the Holmes field scout group
he's got that many members are all these
members are the all local children's
home the answer is majority local people
and there may well be some from adjacent
villages like Barlow and Mill thought
thank you James my boss oh thank you
councilor we can I just ask you please
if you could put some distance I found
it very difficult to get a judge on that
from the from photographs we've seen the
distance between the church Aang's the
proposed site please it's quite a long
distance actually in terms of meet Ridge
and save us something like 20 meters or
even beyond that from the from the back
of the church and don't forget of course
the church has a new modern extension of
a church hall before before we get you
outside
thank you very much for that yes one of
the objects is who said that there is
already a liquid accommodation in the
village I assume he's draining the
parrot the parish church hall and also
the village hall um presumably the
scouts can't use those are not allowed
to use them I can't explain that very
simply the village hall is fully
occupied almost permanently and there is
no storage which is an important aspect
of all Scout accommodation there's so
much equipment like tents and outs or
activity player playing equipment that
requires housing so even if they could
use either of Church Hall or the village
hall that would be simply nowhere to
store any equipment at all and and also
in course remember the important thing
ballgames us obviously played quite a
bit amongst coke Scouts guys etc and
both those buildings are fully glazed
from ceiling to floor and the officer
would be dangerous in breaking yes can I
speak now yes right I have been involved
in the scalp movement for many years
since my own son was a scout cub at six
years old sorry counselor who could be
is this a question at this point oh yeah
it's a statement but you just need
photos as a parish district councillor I
was a pup we need a question or
clarification not statement right let
the scab
quarters were situated in the local
village hall at church hall at a time
mr. Denis has always taught us all
already told you that unfortunately the
church put the chapel to sale and
consequently the Scouts and the Cubs had
to move to branchial Woodhouse 2.5 miles
away now we are so lucky we have a
benefactor in our village who is
protector paired to act as guarantor for
a new build for the new Scout hut the
Scouts encoders belong to the village
when they had to move out we really miss
them particularly in the church and I am
happy to support this application mr.
Witte can I ask a question please when
the extension was put on in the church
the church hall was it not in
consideration for the scouts to move it
there no not at all thank you are there
any further questions that's the posture
teacher a question for counsel wheat
there's a hundred ten members it
currently still meets and a meeting gone
field at a designated Scout pot which is
leased from the tank Council who I
understand I'm if you weren't granted if
the scouts weren't granted who wasn't
granted permission for the purchasing so
did the building of this on this land
what would happen to the scandal would
be continued to meet in Grandville or
would be actually standard are they
being forced out of a drone film or
anything like that is that I think they
wouldn't have any alternative to stay
where they are but the point is that
it's important that we get them back in
the village where they belong where they
were first formed
we've got to attract it close it for
people in the village and further and
further to that counselor what's the
population homes feel I'm distracted
narrow down where these London tential
can come from what things just you know
no one will come out from well I'm
trying to think where these children
live wrong way where they're traveling
to and whether when the fence of parking
so that's what I'm trying to think about
to look at those considerations so
what's the what's the population of
films field well as about 750 houses
throughout the parish
it's a massive parish of course as you
probably appreciate what was the other
question sorry
you wanted to know the size of the
village yeah that's honestly really no
no how big beatific on a day how many
children they are right now I'm looking
where they're coming from whether going
to Luxor okay Thank You counselor
majority of course come from housing
estate adjacent
are there any further questions Thank
You mr. wheat and now we can hear from
burning obvious that
excuse me chair Sweeney was down to
speak as well I haven't gotten on my
list as an objective as I understand
okay thanks mr. Sweeney Lindley is mr.
Sweeney a.m. here oh yes right I'm
basically directed to the residence of
big clothes which adjoins with the back
end of the field to as it was this is my
statement noise from 110 children or may
I know he's only two two nights a week
with the application mentioned it could
be used for other groups there's ever
growing waiting list of applicants to
join Scouts that reach late would this
mean more noise and all these applicants
from the home field area regardless of
equal ease closer at best three to four
meters long and as the field is part of
the proposal we hear parties from chef
Lee Hall dogs barking the hunt channel
use it from the pubs and the peeling of
the church bells which are all further
away than the scout or is it not
reasonable understand to think that it
would be a lot of noise from the scouts
themselves most of households are
retired and elderly and as their
bedrooms back onto the fields will they
have to wait for the children to finish
before they can go to sleep disturbance
is an awful lot of wildlife in the field
as well there's regular nightly visitors
of foxes badges barn owls and occasional
deer during the day there's a sort two
birds such as notches testicles or
peregrine falcon and bullets when the
field no regularly
we had we had the odd nesting lapwings
animal tracks crisscross the field as
most of being well established badger
tracks there we have lots of privacy of
the field overlooks gardens and rear
windows and boom wells on victories
close during a lot look now we had more
than the occasional dog walker wandering
around the fields following the Badger
tracks thinking they were footpaths but
Gardens were not are not big and
sometimes when somebody wanted passed
she would think they were in the back
garden or at your backdoor you can see
straight into the houses and it's not
very pleasant particularly view in
advance ears home field Scouts for an
annual event called though big more
which has caused major problems the
residents and quick release closed the
park we partnered in that bed you've
been able to get off your Drive and if
you're lucky to get out you couldn't get
back to your house if you did say
anything around the risk of being abused
this was not the scout and fault of the
scouts but the participants however the
lack of parking was the new proposal and
I was no other no allowance for visiting
groups or any events run by her from the
building but instead would continue to
rely on the surrounding roads the car
parks remain assuming this second time
application is cross the plan is this
with no major amendments its movement
Forest Park Avenue proposed developments
is still the same it's in a conservation
area adjacent to very - list of
buildings and still situated me about
land that was further down Park Avenue
are on previously used building
previously you before building and
whether a modern design or not as they
are surrounding surrounded by trees and
hedge rules sorry are there any
questions mr. Sweeney
no thanks very much we move on to the
agent rollin Bolger
hello there Thank You mr. Bolton and
thank you for your patience no worries
at all if you'd like to I have three
minutes
yes this proposal is for the third
column skill discount group which was
originally based in church hall until it
was sold until 2000 in 2000 late the new
church or between the church and the
application site is unsuitable because
it has no outside air scouting
activities has no place based and not
suitable for indoor scouting activities
in times of inclement weather most
importantly is not available any evening
during the week as you've heard
presently the scare approved shared
accommodation in the indrawn field and
this is unsatisfactory for all the
reasons set out in the Scout masters
letter which is in Appendix two of our
planning statement which you will have
read the benefits of the proposal
therefore that it will enable the
well-established and proper discount
good to attend to in the community it
serves it will provide a safe
environment for local children has
direct access to a large air factor
activities has internal storage space
outdoor equipment it has access to
washrooms for outdoor activities and has
safe access to drop-off and pickup it
compared to the present position the
office of the recommending we refuse to
partly based on the conclusion of the
science the hut is primarily for indoor
recreation and hosting appropriate
development in the Greenbelt this is a
planning judgment and if your experience
like line is at Scout house
unnecessarily to facilitate allocation
then the proposed would not be an
appropriate development offices
conclusions actually runs contrary to
the reasons given by the Scout Troop
relocated back into the village which
include access to the larger outdoor
area the ability to store outdoor
equipment and access to washrooms
from outdoors a clubhouse of support and
facilitates outdoor recreation is not
inappropriate developed in the Green
Mountain
kinda special circumstances there are 17
letters of support that have been
extended from local MP district
councillors as well as existing in past
past councillors you've heard how the
tariff counts were actively pushing
south group to submit the application
and the importance they have the parish
by 17 letters of support Ward the Scout
group is described as big a hugely
important part of the local community
and vitally important to the development
of local children
turning to the impact on heritage the
heritage statement submitted includes
there'll be no significant harm women's
church or the conservation area because
the key elevation in the 30 seconds
remain the application site is to the
north the application is heavily
screened and the use of stone and dark
grey pictures is suitable for the
materials of the conservation area it is
for you to determine whether the
proposal is necessary to spell all
outdoor application if it is and I would
suggest that points in favor of it being
granted if not you should have the
balance between between the limited
adverse impact impacts of the proposal
and the obvious benefits this balance
was decided in favour in a similar case
in wakeful which our formulation Google
I respectfully ask it committee approve
this application thank you thank you are
there any questions for mr. Bolton no
thank you
tries to read his invocation shout out
speech okay councillor ito yes chan I
just want to ask the gentleman obviously
this think the greenfield site and you
know have you considered other sites
around the area which are brown brown
field and suitable for building on have
you looked at other places the - tanning
is is that the the Scout ku and the
pants Council have thought since they
moved out in 2008 to try and find a
suitable site within the
and they've been unable to do so that's
understandable given that there are
limited I would say brownfield sites
within the village and also of course
being a scout group they're not in they
don't have the ability if you like to
access the funds to purchase to purchase
plans with otherwise be unsuitable for
commercial development and therefore the
fact that this they have been they have
been given the opportunity if you like
to acquire this land and have a building
put on it as a sort of manufacture is it
easy really of the opportunity for them
to to come back to the village
you
are there any further questions Koster
Thank You chair a bit a few times about
come back to the village from from
different speakers one were the scouts
last in the village before they went to
compile the the younger people younger
Scouts went immediately in 2008 when the
Churchill will not let you go but when
the cure told always sold the old Scouts
TV go used to start trying to use your
barn but that barn had no toilet
facilities and really wasn't suitable
and they left and the oldest count left
a couple of years later I'm not quite
sure the date I know mr. week will be
and and they've been looking to come
back ever since so it's over decade
they've been seeking to come back in to
the village
thank you thank you any further
questions Thank You mr. Bolton
and I'd like trying on video laughter
planning manager aging Kirkham to take
us through any clarification point sighs
I'm sorry I've got someone here it's a
question for Adrian all clarification
when the extension was built to the
church and upon application came in my
understanding was that one of the
reasons for wanting this extension was
to house the scalped now mr. Wheatley
wheat has said that that's not the case
can you clarify whether it was when we
improved the application for the
extension to the church
hmmm swimmy chair
in terms of the logistic Asian that
accompanied that application back in
2006 one of the specifics that were set
out in the supporting statement is that
the extension to the the church to form
a new church hall would actually
accommodate the the Scout group that
I'll just quote you hear from it chair
if I can find it here
just a little
to lose one of the justifications for
that extension to the church all in that
case share was to accommodate various
other uses yes I think I found it out in
addition to usage of the church along
Sundays in the bizzy's that the new
building would provide still thriving
and inclusive beaver covering scam group
to use the existing church or the
after-school Club run by the church on
Mondays of currently taking practically
in children so as part of that
justification chair there was just that
beaver cooking scam groups would use
that extension and ultimately chair and
as I found a number of occasions you
need to judge this application on its
merits but certainly in that case that
was one of the the reasons behind the
extension to be the church to form the
new church hall that was given hopefully
that helps shed just trying to weigh up
you know because the church is already
in Greenbelt and if we start on other
piece of property in there that we are
going to be erode in that Greenbelt area
very rapidly thank you for the
clarification
and you further questions for thank you
no thank you
counselor reader yes I know I know the
last application doesn't bear any
relevance to this application but again
we're talking about green belt so again
I just want to draw on a little bit of
the question in that counselor Foster
was making in the last application to
this application in terms of public
benefit so on page 44 it was talked
about in the report the instance of
public benefits weighing out that in it
and you know that the officers have come
to the conclusion that the public
benefits you know during outweigh the
harm to be to the area so I just want to
draw her on and what councilor foster
was saying previously is that we've got
to sort of look at this as a greenfield
site and nobody would want the scouts to
have a place more than myself you know
working in Children Services you know I
would totally want them to have a place
to go but obviously were considering
planning matters in this in this case so
in terms of that again I don't know if
you can answer this Adrian as you've
said previously but what would when you
talk about benefits what do you mean by
that I don't know if you can answer that
I'm sorry and well as I mentioned to
council Foster Lyon I can't tell you as
the decision-maker I think Vicki I can't
tell you how much weight to place on the
the benefits that are being pulled
forward and therefore the very special
circumstances but what I will say chair
in this instance is that officers are
firmly the view that is inappropriate
develop being a new development new
building aren't in the green belt and
you heard mr. Bolton earlier on referred
to an appeal decision of a scale
facility in Wakefield well in that
instance the inspector in that instance
didn't conclude that the facility was to
support outdoor door and
and he took that I think it was a he I
apologize if it wasn't think it was he
concluded that because of the nature of
the accommodation that was proposed and
the scale of the accommodation grows and
I think that runs over into this
application to in the scale and the
nature of the accommodation that's
proposed I don't think it's a building
that you would normally say is say a
changing facility for a football field
it's more than that more provided indoor
space as well just in terms of the the
harm first of all to the Greenbelt
officers in this instance of taking the
view that and that we have because in
this instance and it wasn't a conclusion
on the the other application those case
the readers referred to that I don't
think it's useful to try and just make a
distinction between the two
in this instance officers take the view
that the harm to the Greenbelt in this
case is greater because the distance
that the building is from other building
development in and around it so it will
be a new building in the Greenbelt or
disassociated from other buildings and
again that is a distinction that sets it
aside in the way of your case that mr.
Bolton and to where the inspector
weighed those things about how the new
structure albeit being in Greenbelt
related to other buildings and also in
that case hit occupied and deer in the
land whereas this although the
photographs aren't fantastically
depicted at this it does sit on the head
of the field then falls away to the to
the bungalow that we saw so really wrong
so in an office of you in this case the
harm to the Greenbelt is in an office of
you amplified taking that into account
and we don't believe that the benefit of
of the Scout facility which and react
except members will meet away but we
don't believe because of the harm to the
Greenbelt because of those circumstances
the distance from other build form its
prominence and its isolation
comparatively speaking
officers concluded that those are the
circumstances brought forward don't
outweigh those considerations in this
case and just finally I appreciate Kerry
didn't mention this chair would hope I'm
sure I'm just mentioning it members also
need to consider the location of the
site within the conservation area and
and you've discussed materials as well
and
materials are very similar to those that
were proposed for the new bull housing
just down the way so again that needs to
be consideration for you would but also
and mister mr. Bolton did mentioned this
to the impact on the setting of the
listed building needs to be taken into
account and I think the the photographs
do show that there is some visual
interaction between the two so you do
need to take special regard of that to
and how the building would impact on the
way that that harity asset is enjoyed in
some form from the the site and there
are footpaths and plenty of public
activity in the in the area and again
there's always share over that's helped
as the read
Thank You vibes for the clarification if
needed
counselor posture
you
Thank You chair thank you very much yeah
a question for Adrian I understand the
public benefit and I know I was there as
counsel seeing members here we have to
weigh that public benefit against
possible harm to the green belt but in
this case we can actually define public
benefit I think all of us here like
we've heard the people speak from Holmes
field some of the people which actually
define the actual public benefit it's
quite easy to because the scabs that
will be benefited but Mayor that's one
point the other point it's a question it
says in a 7.4 on page 43 the officers be
Apophis isn't that the bill would be
primarily for indoor recreation so
specifically this if it was for outdoor
recreation would that make a difference
in the recommendations or the views of
officers so the recommendations or the
views are official courses if we're
outdoors thank you and coming on the on
this one and ultimately I would say not
because the policy consideration isn't
merely that it would be for solely for
outdoor recreation or principally for
outdoor recreation but it also has to
preserve the openness of the green belt
so we would say that a building of this
scale on an otherwise undeveloped parcel
of land would undoubtedly have an impact
on the openness of the green belt and
therefore would fail that policy
requirement notwithstanding whether it
would be for outdoor sport or
principally for indoor recreation as
we've concluded and as Adrian alluded to
previously an inspector on the Wakefield
Appeal decision also suggested that a
scalpel in that instance wouldn't be
primarily for outdoor sport and
recreation thank you that thank you any
further questions
deathly silence thank you again and
rightly move on to the last part of this
then what
does anyone want to put a motion forward
a second our last second but those in
favor counselor reader yeah I was going
to second it okay Nick yeah I'm
intending to do is through a roll call
yes no Barry has put the notion forward
to reject application sorry
Ches are we going to move to the boat
and I'll be doing it by roll call so
I'll ask each name in turn if you could
indicate for against or abstention if
members to could turn on the cameras if
they have them off currently now's the
William Armitage cassa jane Barry Oh
how's Andrew Cooper
now sir Mark Foster so counsel Carol
Carol Huckabee I'll stay how's the MOE
parts for cancer Alan Powell
Oh Castle Jacky Ridgeway for councillor
Kathy rouse yeah
and finally chair yourself counselor
Diana ruff
back at ears
ten votes four and one abstention chair
therefore it Ari
thank you very much a notion to approve
officer recommendations has been
characteristic parity if I'm a chair
just just very briefly I'd like to make
a couple of points on this I won't be
team members any longer though it's been
a long afternoon already so just bear
with me a second first of all chair
members will know there's been a whole
number of Appeals launched since March
and that's partly because we've not
reporting eight-inch Marge
so that is reflective of that but also
just to twist members to note the amount
of Appeals that we have and therefore he
does have an impact on how and we do
with those and we resort them so just to
us members to note that chair and then
the other point that just wanted to cast
members to note in the appeals allowed
the appeal allowed on page fifty two the
top of page 52 relates to an application
at Green Lane and drawn field and in
that instance and award of costs has
been made against the council and I just
wanted to use that chair to ask members
to to note that and in his decision on
the costs award the inspector set out
that he didn't feel that the council
have been able to make any substantive
bring forward any substantive technical
evidence in support the reason to refuse
the the application which was primarily
on highway grounds members may remember
so I just wanted to use that chair if I
may to reiterate that members are
clearly able to make whichever decision
they believe on climbing grounds is
approached in any given circumstance but
when that is tested on appeal unless we
can bring forward evidence to support
that we are as a council at risk of
having costs awarded against this as in
this case so it's just chair twice
members to know that
and we're we're discussing particularly
technical issues to remember the
advising members on those points when we
ask for evidence to support them that
can then be tested and stand up would
appeal we are seeking to protect the
counselors position and we're not merely
seeking to and subvert the wishes of
members that may be properly consider
chair so when just went into the class
members to know that and seat elbows in
advising you as officers going forwards
on those particular those technical
issues happy to take any questions you
have that was the only point I wanted to
make and thank you thank you
questions for Adrian counselor each way
yes it's I don't know if I can bring it
up now do we have any other business I
just want to bring something up for
Adrian basically I think I said
yesterday Adrian I really enjoyed the
virtual viewing that we did yesterday
and it's really helped me today sitting
here having the planning meeting and I
just wondered whether it would be
something that we could send out to all
all people on the planning committee
even the substitutes because I just feel
that sometimes like me I work you know
on a Monday when people go out to do the
site visits then I come into planning
and I'm sitting there thinking I don't
know what's going on here because I only
get a glimpse of the pictures that you
you put up so I just wondered if it was
something that the committee would be
happy to for us to do if the officers
are okay with it
gerrae I don't know whether Richard
wants to come in I'll I'll say a few
words and hopefully not to contradict
anything he was going to say and but
first of all I'm grateful for those
comments and Castle Ridgeway because and
what we did yesterday was a was a first
up and I'm pleased at work out in a
helpful way for members I do think as
officer who was in the option and
direction of those and video clips that
we can learn something from it and just
make them slightly less frantic and in
consultation with Nicky and Al and we
all look
and better ways of doing that and
hopefully adding a commentary and just
on the substantive point you make as a
Ridgeway I personally know problems in
providing anything to members that helps
you in your decision-making up that's
what we as officers are here to do in
your deliberations as I'm in committee
we do C to help you with all the
information that you need so I have no
problems with that it's just how we
organize the timings of all those things
but there looks just logisitics and
personally I have no problems with and
providing that there's a standalone
piece of information perhaps with
commentary and or undertaking a virtual
site making as we did for yesterday for
those members who are able to attend but
anything we can do to help in any
feedback we had on yesterday's virtual
site visit it's helpful I'm just
grateful that members did find it useful
I was a bit concerned that the video
coach were a bit we're a bit frantic and
mr. Spielberg perhaps wouldn't have
wanted them being in general and
laziness and on a bit of a learning
curve with how to do things virtually
for everyone's benefit not just funding
committee members and substitutes but
also for the public as well and these
suggestions are very welcome and we will
work on trying to make make them work
for you for the future and I think that
some of the debate that we had yesterday
for those that ever hit attend on screen
was was very helpful in trying to
understand some of the more difficult
aspects of was about so there's a lot of
food for thought that we are actively
working on to make to make life easier
and more understandable for yourself and
all participants in in the committee's
oh yes this is a
later I'm sure
thank you is that it promoted buddy
well thank you all for this afternoon I
think it went off well for our first
attempt and I wish you all a good
evening
hello
you